Herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nr. 35. Und ich weiß, ihr werdet alle schwerstens schockiert sein, dass wir irgendwie so schnell noch eine Folge produzieren.
Wir sind genauso schockiert wie ihr. Aber jemand im Internet lag falsch.
Wieso, was sagt der?
Nein, erkennst du nicht den XKCD?
Ach so, ja, genau, ich kann den noch nicht.
Someone is wrong on the Internet. Someone is wrong on the Internet. Und da konnten wir unsere Klappe nicht halten.
Genau, weil wir gerade feststellen, dass jede Menge Leute wrong on the Internet sind und darüber müssen wir heute mal reden. Wir haben auf die letzte Folge lustigerweise eine Menge Feedback bekommen. Schön, dass ihr uns noch zuhört, finden wir gut. Die Fragen, die daraus entstanden sind, sind unter anderem in die Richtung, wie verhält man sich eigentlich richtig in Diskursen und was ist eigentlich das Ziel davon? Wir hatten ja schon häufiger mal über Diskursen debattiert. Mit Schormacher zum Beispiel, was so die Auswirkungen sind, was so die Möglichkeiten sind. Mit Lobe hatten wir auch darüber diskutiert und welche Probleme wir gerade so sehen, insbesondere jetzt halt im Internet. Und gerade geht ja gerade die Diskussion los über diese Facebook-Lösch-Debatte. Also die Frage, sollte Facebook eingreifen? Sollte es da, wie ihre Community regeln oder Gemeinschaftsregeln, wie es schon auf Deutsch heißt, sollten sie die darum gehen erweitern, dass man nicht mehr gegen Einwanderung sein darf zum Beispiel? Oder wo liegt da die Grenze? Was ist sozusagen der moralische Grundkonsens, der ethische Minimalstandard, der entforst werden sollte? Also wo man sagt, okay, da muss halt irgendwie eingegriffen werden. Und wir haben da natürlich ein relativ großes Feld, inzwischen bei Facebook als amerikanische Firma, die ja dann halt eher den amerikanischen Standards von Meinungsfreiheit folgt versus den deutschen Ansichten dazu. Die versuchen sich ja immer so ein bisschen so anzupassen. Aber darum geht es uns eigentlich nicht so richtig im Kern, weil es ja letztendlich ist es halt Facebook. Und da habe ich jetzt irgendwie nicht so viele Ambitionen, was diese Plattform angeht, da irgendwas zu wuppen. Aber die Frage stellt sich ja an möglichen anderen Orten. Also überall eigentlich da, wo Diskussionen stattfinden, wo Meinungsraussatz stattfindet, darüber, dass es halt verkommen ist, dass wir da halt irgendwie eine Menge Leute haben, die ja nur noch irgendwie eher weniger nützliche oder auch nur halbwegs lesbare oder auch nur in deutscher Sprache verfasste Posts schreiben. Da brauchen wir eigentlich nicht wirklich darüber reden, weil mich interessieren eigentlich schon mehr so die Strategien von Leuten, die ich nach für intellektuell satisfaktionsfähig halte. Wieso das bei denen auch so entgleist? Also wieso bei denen es halt nicht mehr möglich ist, eine Debatte zu führen?
Eigentlich ist es ja auch nur unser Aufhänger gerade. Im Grunde eitert dieses Problem ja schon länger vor sich hin, also bei mir zumindest, weil ich häufiger beobachten kann, dass Kritik kommt, die durchscheinen lässt, dass der andere überhaupt nicht verstandet, warum es mir geht und eine andere Art von Diskurs offenbar führt als ich. Und deswegen liegt mir das auf dem Herzen heute mal auch zu, ein bisschen zu erklären, wie wir, Frank und ich, Diskurs pflegen. Und die Kernthese will ich mal vorbringen ist, dass man in ein Gespräch reingeht, mit dem Ziel widerlegt zu werden. Naja, nicht seine Sachen zu verteidigen, das versucht man natürlich auch. Aber wenn ich...
Mindestens mit der Bereitschaft widerlegt zu werden. Das muss ich im Moment das Ziel sein so, aber zumindest muss ich die Bereitschaft mitbringen, dass ich annehme, dass meine Position entweder nicht vollständig ist oder nicht richtig ist. Also, dass sie halt faktisch falsch ist.
Also, widerlegt heißt jetzt auch nicht irgendwie 100 Prozent widerlegt. Aber das Ziel, ich finde tatsächlich das Ziel, ich will das mal so spieletheoretisch mit so einem Ausgangsdiagramm irgendwie beschreiben. Ja, wenn ich mich mit jemandem unterhalte, sagen wir mal zwei Stunden, und am Ende habe ich die ganze Zeit recht gehabt, dann habe ich ja nichts gewonnen in der Zeit. Ja, intellektuell völlig sinnlos. Wenn ich merke, dass der Ideen hat, an die ich noch nicht gedacht habe, dann habe ich was gelernt. Und wenn sich rausstellt, dass ich kompletter nebenlag, dann ist für mich der intellektuelle beste Ausgang. Weil dann kann ich nicht nur drüber nachdenken, erstmal völlig neues Gedanken gerüst, sondern dann kann ich auch drüber nachdenken, warum ich denn falsch lag. Ob ich vielleicht an meinem Verhalten was ändern kann. Also ich finde jetzt nicht Ziel im Sinne von ich gehe rein, um auf die Fresse zu kriegen, sondern ich gehe rein mit dem Ziel, am Ende mich fortgebildet zu haben.
Das heißt, das Ziel ist das Kronos, das Dialog ist ja, also es ist für mich in der Regel ein Hinterher, irgendwie weiter zu sein. So entweder halt Dinge besser verstanden zu haben oder bessere Handlungsoptionen zu haben, so weil mir plötzlich mehr Handlungsoptionen offenstehen oder auch festzustellen, dass ich mit Dingen völlig falsch lag, was auch okay ist, weil dann handel ich nicht mehr falsch, also dann gehe ich halt nicht mehr von falschen Prämissen aus. Das heißt also, die Möglichkeit seinen Standpunkt zu ändern und genau diesen Standpunkt nicht als ideologisch festgefahrenes Dogma zu betrachten, halte ich für absolut essenziell, wenn man sich auseinandersetzt. Und irgendwie scheint mir, dass diese Bereitschaft sehr vielen Leuten irgendwie abgeht. So und ich weiß nicht, ist so diese Usenet-Sozialisierung so, die wir da so haben? Ich glaube ja.
Also ich würde sogar so weit gehen zu sagen, es muss gar nicht meine Position sich ändern oder die Fakten. Aber wenn sich mein Verständnis dessen ändert, was eigentlich das Problem ist, was ich gerade zu lösen versuche, habe ich auch schon gewonnen.
Oder mein Verständnis davon, wie der andere die Welt sieht und warum er dieser Meinung ist.
Die meisten Konflikte bestehen ja eigentlich gar nicht aus faktischen Differenzen, sondern bestehen daraus, wie man die Welt sieht, wie man die Fakten einordnet. Und alleine der Abgleich mit anderen Leuten, um zu sehen, wie die dieselbe Sache, dasselbe Konzept einordnen in ihre Welt, kann schon echt weiterbringen.
Wobei man natürlich jetzt sehen muss, dass wir an verschiedenen Stellen, insbesondere in den USA, aber auch zunehmend in Deutschland, ja diese Aufspaltung des Faktenuniversums haben. Also, dass die Leute nicht mal mehr in der Lage sind, überhaupt irgendeine Art von Gespräch zu führen oder Diskurs zu führen, weil sie von einer völlig verschiedenen Faktenbasis ausgehen. So, gerade exemplarisch zu beobachten, halt dieser ganzen Genderdebatte, wo das eine Extrem halt sagt, Geschlecht ist rein biologisch definiert, das andere Extrem sagt, Geschlecht ist rein sozial definiert. Und beide liegen halt komplett falsch. Und die Frage, wieso die sich überhaupt nicht mehr unterhalten können, resultiert halt daraus, dass sie von völlig verschiedenen Arten, von Fakten ausgehen und natürlich auch die ganzen Unzulänglichkeiten der modernen Wissenschaft, was einfach die Aussagefähigkeit von Studien und so weiter angeht, natürlich auch weitlich ausnutzen, um nicht mehr miteinander reden zu müssen.
Ich finde, das ist ein gutes Beispiel, wobei ich jetzt eher den Arbeitsmarkt genommen hätte, weil man ja eine Beobachtung machen kann, die ich sehr essenziell finde, nämlich, dass die Fakten tatsächlich gar nicht anders sind. Aber wie sie ins Weltgerüst eingebaut werden, ist anders. Das heißt, da kommt dann so was wie die Regierung erklärt, wir haben so viel Arbeitsplätze geschaffen. Und dann kommen die Linken und sagen, ja, aber das sind alles irgendwie Zeitarbeiter, das sind keine echten. Oder dem gegenüberstehen. Also das heißt, die Fakten sind an sich dieselben, aber sie werden komplett anders dargestellt. Die Fakten sind, naja, also es sind so Wortklappereien und Spinnendoktorscheiße, die dazu führen, dass die eine Seite sagt, das sind aber Arbeitsplätze und dadurch so tut, als gäbe es da Fakten, die aber gar nicht da sind. Ja, das heißt, die benutzen ihren, legen ihren Interpretationsspielraum noch weiter aus als sonst, damit sie Fakten behaupten können, die eigentlich gar nicht da sind.
Okay, aber gut, die an der Definition rumzuschrauben, ist ja ein legitimes Mittel des Diskurses. Also das ist ja tatsächlich was, wo man jetzt irgendwie nicht unbedingt sagen muss, dass das halt völlig illegitim ist.
Andererseits, übrigens diese Gender-Sache würde ich so auch nicht stehen lassen. Ich glaube, das ist ein Symptom dessen, dass wir einfach, da kommen wir später noch zu in der Sendung, das ist glaube ich ein Symptom dessen, dass die Leute sich gar nicht mehr frühzeitig in ihrem Diskurs mit der anderen Seite unterhalten, sondern dass sie einfach ein festes Modell haben, die davon, was die andere Seite denkt. Ich glaube, weder die Gender-Leute behaupten, dass es kein biologisches Geschlecht gibt, noch die Biologen behaupten, dass es...
Aber die andere Seite nimmt sie als Vernein.
Genau, aber man redet zu spät in dem gesamten Prozess überhaupt erst miteinander, weil man vorher versucht, sich seine Argumente so perfekt hinzulegen, dass sie unwiederlegbar scheinen.
Und mit den Definitionen zu spielen.
Genau, die Definitionen.
Die Gender-Leute sagen ja, na komm, wir unterschreiten Gender und Sex. Sex ist das Biologische und Gender ist das soziale Konstrukt. Und die Biologisten sagen halt so, ist ja völliger Bullshit, das kann man sowieso nicht auseinanderhalten. Das heißt, die Faktenbasis, auf der die beiden Seiten argumentieren, hat nur noch begrenzten Kontakt zur Realität. Da tritt dann dieser Effekt ein, dass die eine Seite sagt so, wir können sowieso nicht mehr miteinander reden, weil du redest, hast benutzt andere Worte, benutzt Worte, die eine andere Bedeutung der Worte haben. Also zum Beispiel der Klassiker sind dann halt solche Sachen, wo Termini in der Wissenschaft dasselbe Wort benutzen, aber eine völlig andere oder zumindest eine spezifischere Bedeutung haben als der Altersbegriff. Das ist ein absoluter Klassiker, was immer wieder vorkommt.
Jedes Mal Probleme macht.
Jedes Mal richtig harte Probleme macht. Und die Folge davon ist dann, dass man sich anfängt, man weigert sich, sich zu unterhalten. Ich beobachte das gerade in so einem anderen Thema, nämlich diese Automatisierungsdebatte. Da driften gerade auch die Fakten komplett auseinander. Also da gibt es halt so die, die sagen, okay, wir gucken uns jetzt gerade an, wie der Arbeitsmarkt sich spaltet. Wir sehen halt irgendwie im niedrigsten Lohnniveau, nimmt die Anzahl der Arbeitsplätze zu. Im höchsten Lohnniveau nimmt die Anzahl der Arbeitsplätze zu und in der Mitte verschwindet es. So, und also klare Automatisierungsfolge, weil halt irgendwie einfachste Tätigkeiten.
Für dich klar.
Für mich klar, logischerweise. Und dann kommt das Gegenteil, die sagen halt so, ja, aber eigentlich nimmt die Anzahl der Arbeitsplätze ja gar nicht ab, sondern die nimmt ja sogar leicht zu.
So, und es ist auch alles super.
So, und dann guckst du dir wiederum an, so wie wird dann eigentlich diese, deswegen drehen an den Statistiken. Weil was der Punkt, von dem nämlich niemand redet, ist nämlich die Statistik, die der Anzahl der Leute, die überhaupt noch am Arbeitsmarkt teilnehmen. Und tatsächlich ist es zum Beispiel in den USA so, dass die Bevölkerung leicht wächst, aber die Anzahl der Arbeitsplätze wächst nicht im selben Maße mit, sondern die ist stagnierend bis sinkend. Das heißt, was daraus folgt, ist, dass der Anteil der Leute überhaupt am Arbeitsmarkt mitspielen. Das heißt, sich überhaupt um den Job irgendwie kümmern fällt.
Na und, du hast noch den Effekt, dass die Leute mehr als einen Job zur Zeit machen.
Das kommt noch dazu. Aber wir sehen halt so dieses Problem, halt über so relativ komplexe Themen zu debattieren, ist schwierig in dem Sinne, dass man erst mal versuchen muss, sich halt irgendwie auf derselben Faktenbasis irgendwie zu finden. Also dass man sagt, okay, wir leben halt in derselben Welt, wir haben zumindest ähnliche Einschätzungen, ja, wirst du sagen, dessen, was da irgendwie geht und was möglich ist. Und daraus folgt dann vielleicht eine Diskussion darüber, wie man halt irgendwie damit umgeht, also was halt die Lösungen sind.
Ich sehe das, also ich unterstelle dir jetzt mal, was was nicht da ist, aber so für die Debatte. Ich glaube nicht, dass das Zufall ist, sondern das sind Spin-Doktoren am Werk, die absichtlich so die Statistiken zurecht drehen, bis sich daraus was Positives abgeziehen lässt. Das heißt, es ist nicht so, dass die Debatten-Teilnehmer am Ende mit schlechten Fakten arbeiten, sondern das ist einfach die Datenbasis, die sie haben, weil dazwischen so eine Schicht aus Spin-Doktoren ist, die versucht, die Statistiken hinzuschieben. Und die Formulierung, die ich wählen würde, ist jetzt nicht Fakten-Basis, sondern Koordinatensystem. Oder in der Mathematik redet man von einer Basis. Ja, dass man sagt, wenn ich sage, drei Schritte nach rechts, dann meine ich dasselbe rechts wie du. Darauf müssen wir uns einigen. Die Fakten lassen sich ja in jedem Koordinatensystem abbilden, wenn es eine Basis ist. Aber man muss sich zumindest einigen, im selben Koordinatensystem zu reden. Und da hört es ja schon auf, weil das ja mit Absicht eben nicht gemacht wird. Sondern es passieren so Sachen wie, die Gegenseite bringt Argument so und so. Und da taucht dieser Kampfbegriff auf. Ja, oder halt jetzt nicht Kampfbegriff, sondern benutzt als Kampfbegriff Arbeitsplätze. Das ist ja fast alles. Alle Begriffe sind ja irgendwie Kampfbegriffe in solchen umkämpften Gebieten. Und dann mach ich eine Statistik, die diesen Begriff zwar benutzt, aber in versucht, subtil anders auszulegen, damit mein Argument besser aussieht. Ja, und das ist, glaube ich, das Hauptproblem, dass im Grunde die meisten Leute gar nicht mehr tatsächlich Zugriff zu den Fakten haben, sondern wir haben nur Zugriff auf gefilterte Partisanen-Informationen, die von irgendwelchen Leuten schon so genudget wurden, dass sie in deren Bild effektiver in Argumentationen reinpassen.
Ich glaube eigentlich eher, also häufiger haben wir eher das Problem, dass die interessanten Fakten weggelassen werden.
Aha, gut, bei Automatisierung jetzt.
Überhaupt, also nehmen wir zum Beispiel mal dieses Problem, was wir vor einer Weile mal diskutiert hatten. Die Frage, wie würde es denn den Staaten gehen, wenn sie plötzlich keinen Schuldendienst mehr leisten müssen? Wären die Haushalte, die wir da haben, irgendwie so einigermaßen ausgeglichen oder wie defizitär wären die eigentlich, wenn die plötzlich keinen Schuldendienst mehr machen müssten und auch keine Einkommen aus Sachen, die sie verborgt haben, bekommen würden? Und stellt sich raus, es ist eine hölleschwierige Aufgabe. Also es gibt da zwar irgendwie so Maßzahlen, die kann man auch irgendwie so mit ein bisschen buddeln finden, aber ist jetzt nicht so. Also es ist eher so ein Passivmarketing, so auf den Statistikseiten. Muss man sich dann irgendwie zusammenfummeln und aus verschiedenen Tabellen zusammenrechnen und so. Und man bekommt so den Eindruck, dass das halt eine Sache ist, über die die Volkswirtschaftler zwar gerne so unter sich diskutieren. Na also was halt für die so ein...
Aber eine informierte Debatte wollen die nicht, ne?
Die wollen keine öffentliche Debatte. Also keine, keine, also so eine, also eine Debatte, wo sie riskieren würden, dass jemand sagt, klingt aber eigentlich ganz real, lass mal diesen ganzen Schuldenscheiß einweg machen, so.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es damit zusammenhängt, sondern ich glaube, dass es so eine Verteidigung ihres Gebietes ist gegen Leute von außen. Mir ging es neulich so, als ich recherchieren wollte, wie viel Vermögen eigentlich die Deutschen haben. Und die Zahl, die immer umgereicht wird, ist das Bruttovermögen. Also man muss natürlich die Verbindlichkeiten abziehen, sonst ist ja nicht Vermögen. Und die Zahl, kannst du mal suchen.
Gibt's nicht, oder wie?
Ja, nee, weil passt nicht. Ja, dass es überhaupt erhoben wird, liegt meines Erachtens daran, dass es sich für Partisanengeschichten einigt. Eignet, dass wir sagen, so viel Vermögen, wir müssen reich sein oder...
Also parteiliche Geschichten.
Ja.
Partisanen ist ja...
Nee, also Partisanen jetzt im politischen Sinn, vor das wir halt irgendwie verschiedene Fronten haben und jeder hat ihre Agenda. Und dann werden eben genau die Zahlen erhoben, die sich dafür eignen, eine dieser Agenda-Argumente voranzutreiben. Und so ein Interesse daran, dass die Bevölkerung einfach die Fakten sieht und abwägen kann, hat, glaube ich, niemand, weil dann bliebe nur noch eine Position übrig und das System wird imponiert.
Was wir gerade sehen, so zum Beispiel in dieser Flüchtlingsdebatte, ist ja auch der Versuch, Dinge jetzt nicht so prominent darzustellen, die halt nicht in den gerade populären Narrativ passen. Also ich sehe da schon gerade auch das Problem, dass von Schwierigkeiten, die es halt einfach gibt in der Logistik der Versorgung von so vielen Leuten, die irgendwie ankommen und von dem Land hier relativ wenig Ahnung haben, was vollkommen normal ist, und doch die möglicherweise harte Konflikte untereinander haben, dass die Probleme in maximal in der Lokalpresse stattfinden. Manchmal finden sie es in der Bundespresse statt, aber in der Regel müssen die Leute dann zu irgendwie so einem Scheiß wie AT Deutsch gehen, wo sie halt dann halt irgendwie so nur zwei Klicks vom Kopfverlag entfernt sind, um halt irgendwie zumindest irgendwie so ein Basisgefühl dafür zu bekommen, ok, vielleicht doch nicht alles so super rosig und wir müssten da einfach echt viel mehr tun.
Und das ist richtig gefährlich. Weiß nicht, ob du die Geschichte von deinem Kollegen erzählen willst?
Ja, also ich kenne halt Leute, die arbeiten halt professionell im Flüchtlingswesen so, also die sind halt weltweit unterwegs für Internationalisationen, ich sage jetzt gerade noch nicht welche, und managen halt Flüchtlingslager. Und was die halt erzählen ist halt super krass, weil die müssen halt damit umgehen, dass die da Konflikte haben unter den Flüchtlingen, die also teilweise sehr alt sind, teilweise Stämme oder auch Großfamilien relativ nahe aufeinander hocken, die sonst irgendwie durch geografische Entfernung getrennt waren und deswegen halt ihre Konflikte nur sporadisch ausgelebt haben, und die sitzen jetzt so quasi zelt an zelt. Und die dann halt mit sehr drakonischen Maßnahmen, also was die so erzählen, so wie halt so ein, zum Beispiel UN-Flüchtlingslager gemanagt wird, so ein großes, wo halt irgendwie mehrere 10.000, 100.000 Leute sind, ist halt eine ziemlich drakonische Angelegenheit. Die müssen halt einfach sicherstellen, dass alle zu Essen kriegen, dass alle medizinische Versorgung kriegen, dass alle Wasser haben, dass die sinditäre Einrichtung funktioniert.
So bis hin zu Zäunen zwischen den Zeltlagern, intern.
Bis zu Zäunen zwischen den Vierteln, wo halt dann die verschiedenen Stämme und Clans getrennt werden, wenn die halt anfangen, sich da gegenseitig irgendwie zu bekriegen. Und das sind halt so Sachen, das muss man halt wissen. Also das kann man ja weder moralisch positiv noch negativ bewerten. Das ist halt einfach nur ein Fakt, der halt da ist und mit dem man umgehen muss. Und das halt nicht zu tun, sondern so zu tun, als wäre das halt halt eine relativ unproblematische Angelegenheit, so relativ viele Flüchtlinge unterzubringen, halte ich für grundlegend falsch. Weil natürlich ist es richtig, die hier zu haben, aber dann muss man damit halt auch umgehen. Das heißt also positiv betrachtet sagen, okay, wir stellen uns diesen Problem, sowohl den ökonomischen Problem als auch den sozialen Problem und tun nicht so, als wäre das halt alle total einfach. Das ist es nämlich nicht und deswegen finde ich es halt auch schlecht, dass die Linke gerade nicht klar ansagt, okay, wir können sicherlich eine Million Flüchtlinge in Deutschland oder auch mehr unterbringen. Ist logistisch und technisch überhaupt gar kein Problem, wenn wir uns ein bisschen zusammenreißen. Aber dann müssen wir halt an die Kohle von den reichen Leuten ran. Also dann müssen wir halt anfangen, tatsächlich sowas mal wie eine Vermögenssteuer zu haben. Dann müssen wir halt anfangen, dafür zu sorgen, dass irgendwie für die Ausbildung von den Flüchtlingen Geld erhoben wird bei den Leuten, die die ganze Zeit daran verdient haben, dass irgendwie Waffen exportiert wurden und dass Deutschland Exportweltmeister ist. Weil sonst führt das halt dazu, dass es wieder nur am unteren Rand, also da, wo halt die Leute ohnehin schon relativ prekär leben, halt noch schwieriger, noch prekärer wird.
Und da steht aber die Utopie oder ich weiß nicht, welchen Ausdruck man dafür nimmt, da steht so die Ideologie, kann man vielleicht sagen, der war halt im Weg. Und der Einzige, der das ansprechen konnte, war der Vorsitzende des Zentralrats der Muslime in Deutschland. Der hat es jetzt in einem Interview zu Pratikorgehung gesagt, also hört mal zu, die Moslems, die wir hier alle als Flüchtlinge rein kriegen, das ist nicht sicher, dass die sich alle gegenseitig mögen, nur weil die in derselben Situation sind. Und wenn irgendjemand anders das gesagt hätte, dann wäre der aber sofort Rassist und unten durch gewesen. Und das finde ich traurig. Das heißt dann, dass die Debatte schon völlig vergiftet ist, wenn man Fakten nicht ansprechen kann. Und die Linken halt genauso, die können das nicht sagen. Es gibt so diesen Spruch, nur Nixen konnte nach China gehen. Und genauso konnte nur Schröder hier unser Sozialsystem kaputt machen, das konnte nur die SPD machen. Und genauso sieht das jetzt wieder aus. Die Linken sind nicht die, die so was ansprechen können. Und das ist traurig.
Und zumal halt der Punkt ist, dass die, dass gerade aus Sicht der Linken jetzt die politische Gelegenheit wäre. Wo das Land endlich mal sich zusammenrauft und sagt, okay, wir solidarisieren uns dafür, dass wir diesen Flüchtlingen neues Zuhause bauen. Wir wollen, dass Menschen aus vielen Kulturkreisen herkommen und hier irgendwie mit uns eine neue Gesellschaft bauen und dieses langweilige Deutschland mal ein bisschen bunter machen. Und dafür ist es aber notwendig zu sagen, wir müssen dieses Thema der sozialen Gerechtigkeit angehen. Und dafür ist es zwingend notwendig, dass wir uns nicht nur darauf verlassen, dass die Leute auch noch in zwei, drei oder fünf Jahren freiwillig spenden, sondern wir müssen strukturell daran gehen, zu sagen, okay, diese Aufgabe zu finanzieren, erfordert es einfach, an das Geld von den Leuten ranzugehen, die zu viel Geld haben. Und nicht irgendwie bei den Leuten, die ohnehin schon Abstiegsangst haben, halt irgendwie weiter plündern zu gehen, wie das halt Schröder gemacht hat.
Und das ist ja auch genau, was jetzt die fürchtet, der Rechten auslöst, ne?
Beziehungsweise womit die halt ihre Argumentationsbasis unterführt.
Womit die ihre Leute anziehen, na klar.
Genau, dass sie halt sagen, okay, passt auf, so wie es bisher gelaufen ist, wird die Kohle nicht von den Leuten genommen, die sowieso zu viel Kohle haben, sondern von denen, die eh nichts haben. Ihr werdet diejenigen sein, die euch, die sich halt mit den Flüchtlingen, die nicht arbeiten dürfen, weil ihre Bildungsabschlüsse nicht anerkannt werden, um die Jobs am unteren Ende prügeln werden. Und dementsprechend werden eure Löhne da weiter fallen. Natürlich ist dann klar, dass Leute, die in solchen sozialen Umständen leben, dann halt empfänglicher sind. Und insbesondere wenn man sich anguckt, wer wählt dann AfD, wer wählt dann halt die, bzw. ist in diesem Pegidaspektrum unterwegs. Es sind halt meistens in der Regel ältere Leute, Leute aus der unteren Mittelschicht, die Angst vor weiterem Abstieg haben.
Im Grunde arme Würstchen alles. Ich hab ja neulich dieses Blog mir mal angeguckt, was da gibt, was so Nazis bloß stellt und versucht die dann zu denunzieren. Und was ich da davon getragen hab, ist, dass die meisten Leute um dies dagegen waren, irgendwie so angelernter Schweißer mit irgendwie Realschulabschluss und so. Also das sind nicht Leute, wo man sagen kann, das ist nicht die Oberschicht. Und das sind auch nicht Leute, wo man sagen kann, die Fürchte sind irrational, die die haben, sondern die haben einfach in den letzten 10, 20 Jahren schon beobachten können, dass ihnen immer in die Tasche gegriffen wird. Und solange wir diese große Koalition haben, muss man ja auch davon ausgehen, dass hier weiter marodiert wird im sozialen System. Das ist ja nun mal so. Aber dass die Linken das nicht umgesetzt kriegen, finde ich sehr traurig. Schon schon auf einer fundamentaleren Ebene haben wir es ja hier mit einem Ausbruch von Solidarität zu tun, was ja eins der Kernthemen der Linken ist. Die müssten im Oberwasser haben, die müssten im Aufwind sein. Und stattdessen hören wir jetzt so Sachen, wie das den Linken ihre Wahllokale, nicht die Wahllokale, ihre Parteizentralen in irgendwelchen ostdeutschen Bundesländern die Scheiben eingeworfen werden, so täglich. Und dann denkt man so, satt. Die Gewalt entlädt sich ja immer nach unten. Oder, hab das ja immer so als Management-Spruch gehört, shit flows downhill. Was so viel erklärt, wenn man das mal im Hinterkauf behält. Wenn die Gesellschaft auf eine Gruppe von Leuten rauftritt, dann treten die auch noch mal nach unten. Das ist einfach immer so. Irgendwann gibt es niemanden mehr, auf dem man noch treten könnte, aber die Leute, die eh schon unten sind, haben alle Leute über sich, die auch noch mal nach unten treten, um sich von denen abzugrenzen und aus anderen Gründen. Und das kann man denen nicht übel nehmen, solange wir nicht aufhören, auf den prekären Leuten rumzutreten, dürfen wir nicht mit denen böse sein, wenn sie auch noch mal nach unten treten. Das ist als Gesellschaft so, dass man nicht einfach auf die zeigen kann, sondern die gesamte Gesellschaft muss sich dann ändern und mehr solidarisch werden und aufhören, irgendwie Leute zu gängeln beim Arbeitsamt und so. Das sind ja alles Muster, die wir einfach haben in der Gesellschaft.
Was wir stattdessen halt hier sehen, ist, dass die Ängste dieser Leute, dass sie, wenn sie die artikulieren und zugegebenermaßen meistens nicht in besonders intellektuell hochwertige Art und Weise artikulieren, dass das für die eigentlich nur in ihren Echo-Kammern erlaubt zu sein scheint. Also wir sehen halt immer wieder so Ausbrüche, so was weiß ich gerade, dass zum Beispiel Reddit irgendwie Europa quasi von Rechten übernommen worden, die halt da dieses ganze Forum halt einfach durch massives Posten in großen Mengen übernommen haben. Wir sehen es halt natürlich auf Facebook ganz klar, damit hatten wir ja angefangen, dass die...
Weißt du, ich finde man muss sich bei solchen Sachen immer in die Leute versuchen rein zu versetzen. Und wenn ich unten im Prekariat wäre und ich hätte einen Realschulabschluss und wäre vielleicht noch in der zehnten Klasse aus der Schule raus und hätte irgendwie mit Mühe und Not irgendwo eine Lehrstelle als Schweißer gekriegt, da kannst du dich doch nicht wundern, wenn die dann irgendwie Probleme mit ihrem Deutsch haben, wenn die unser Schulsystem nur aus der Ferne gesehen haben. Das ist, das kann man, du kannst auch nicht die Schüler beschimpfen, wenn unser Schulsystem versagt. Das ist unser aller Problem.
Das ist korrekt, aber mich interessiert dir dabei eigentlich mehr, warum diese Debatte, warum die nur untereinander miteinander reden können. Naja, also wir haben ja dabei zwei Effekte. Zum einen haben wir so eine Ausgrenzung, also die Ausgrenzung gegenüber Nazis ist ja eine sehr alte Strategie, zu sagen, wir wollen nicht, dass die legitimiert werden, dass die also durch Teilnahme am gesellschaftlichen Diskurs diese Ideologie normalisiert wird.
Und andersrum natürlich, die Nazis haben ja versucht, die Kommunisten damals mit derselben Strategie rauszukanten. Haben auch versucht, die abzukanzeln und Parteiverbot am Ende ja verfolgt in KZs geschoben. Das ist jetzt natürlich geht weiter als wir heute machen, aber vom Wesen hier ist es auch eine Ausgrenzung.
Na gut, ich meine, und dann in der Bundesrepublik war es ja so, dass man halt, also mit den Kommunisten genauso gemacht hat, also halt die Bruchsverbote, hat der Versuch dieser Strategie, das was man als in Anführungszeichen Extremismus definiert, durch Totschweigen im öffentlichen Diskurs wegzubekommen. Und ich glaube, das ist eine Strategie, die hat nur vor dem Internet funktioniert. Die funktioniert jetzt einfach nicht mehr und zwar dank Internet.
Wir haben so ein paar Thesen gesammelt dazu. Also wir haben uns ein bisschen überlegt. Im Internet eine der ersten Sachen, die man als Vorteil des Internets gesehen hat. Die werden gefeiert, dass es endlich so ist. Es ist egal, wie randgruppig deine Interessenlage ist. Du wirst im Internet, findest du andere Leute, die sie teilen und mit denen kannst du eine soziale Gruppe aufbauen. Und wir haben gedacht, das ist ja super, sind wir alle glücklich und zufrieden. Und jetzt stellt sich aber raus, das gilt eben nicht nur für irgendwelche Anime-Fringe-Geschichten, sondern es gilt eben auch für irgendwelches nationalsozialistisches Gedankengut. Und es kommt ein weiterer Effekt dazu. Franks These ist, das Internet ist einfach zu groß. Und das heißt, alle Leute müssen irgendwelche Filterstrategien entwickeln, um ihre Aufmerksamkeit zu verteilen. Und der häufig eingeschlagene Weg ist, dass man eben aufhört, Sachen zu rezipieren, die nicht eh aus dem eigenen Interessengebiet kommen. Und das ist sehr gefährlich. Das ist eine sehr gefährliche Sache. Wir nennen das immer Echo-Kammer, weil es eben heißt, dass da Gleichgesinnte zusammen sind und einer sagt was, was eh der Rest glaubt und das verstärkt dann nochmal, was der Rest eh schon glaubt. Und dann bestätigt irgendein anderer aus der Echo-Kammer das und die hören im Grunde immer sich gegenseitig und die Echoes von den Wänden von und sagen alle dasselbe. Und haben am Ende das Gefühl, sie sind Teil einer riesigen Bewegung. Und dabei sind es irgendwie 20. Und das klingt jetzt nicht inhärent schlecht, aber es kommt eben dazu, dass man diese Filter-Strategien entwickelt hat und dass man gleichzeitig die anderen Stimmen ausgrenzt und nicht mehr wahrnimmt oder wegfiltert.
Wobei das eben früher durchaus eine strategische Strategie war. Also gerade bei den Nazis war es ja so, dass die Ausgrenzung eine aktive Strategie war, die halt von bis weit rein ins Zentrumspektrum betrieben wurde, um zu verhindern, dass sich da inzwischen in Ostdeutschland so ein Nazi-Kulturraum bildet. Das war halt so in den 90ern. Da hatten wir halt das Problem, dass da eine, ja, also sich gerade auf den Dörfern, so in Brandenburg und Sachsen und so, halt eine rechte Jugendkultur rausgebildet hat, weil es halt nichts anderes gab und die sich halt alle Benachteiligten fühlten und das passte halt irgendwie zum Gesamtnarrativ so.
Na und, ist das ja genau das Alter, in dem man eben auch versucht, sich aufzulehnen?
Genau. Und da war es halt so, dass das halt schon zum Teil erfolgreich war. Also dass halt der... Die Ausgrenzung. Also dass es halt dazu geführt hat, dass der, wenn die halt keine Ressourcen bekommen haben, eben keine rechten Jugendhäuser machen konnten, sich halt irgendwie mit ihren Bands halt halbwegs im Untergrund treffen mussten und das halt alles immer schwierig und teuer für die war. Das hat halt schon dazu geführt, dass dieser Kulturraum weniger stark ausgebreitet hat, als er hätte sich ausbreiten können. Na, es gibt ihn trotzdem und er ist trotzdem, wie wir jetzt gerade so insbesondere in Sachsen sehen, halt irgendwie stark und lebendig, aber eben nicht so groß. Und das Internet hat das halt geändert, weil genau dieser Effekt, dass du im Zweifel für jeden Fetisch, für jede abseitige Meinung oder für jede Ansicht Gleichgesinnte findest, die ähnlicher Meinung sind, die darüber mit dir diskutieren wollen, die dir Fakten liefern, die dich bestarken darin, was ja auch ein wesentlicher Effekt von solchen Gruppendiskussionen ist, die ist halt im Internet nicht mehr zu verhindern. Also man kann halt sagen, okay, ich will solche Leute nicht in meinem Freundeskreis haben, ich will nicht in meinem Twitterfeed mit dieser oder jeder Meinung konfrontiert werden oder ich möchte das einfach nicht lesen, weil mein Leben dadurch besser und schöner wird. Das kann ich vollständig nachvollziehen, das mache ich auch. Also ich habe halt irgendwie auch keinen Bock auf irgendwie Empörte und Plärosusen in meinem Twitterfeed. Aber das führt halt nicht dazu, dass es diese Leute nicht gibt. Das ist halt genauso mit Nazis, das ist halt genauso mit Rechten oder einfach mit fremdenfeindlichen Leuten oder Leuten, die halt ein bisschen schwierig ist zu definieren, sind die jetzt Nazi oder machen die sich nur Sorgen um ihre Rente.
Wobei das ist ja auch eine Gegenstrategie von denen, dieses Spektrum so ein bisschen zu verwischen. Und was davon anfing, damit anfing, dass irgendwie Teile von Nazi-Parteien verboten wurden, aber andere dann nicht. Und dann haben die halt versucht, Organisation zu gründen, die fast dasselbe Programm hatten, aber einen anderen Namen. Und dann haben wir das Programm so ein bisschen angepasst, in der Hoffnung, also um mal so die Grenzen auszuloten. Genau wie was unsere Innenminister mit den Verfassungsgerichtsurteilen machen, haben die Nazis eben auch gemacht mit den Parteiverboten. Und das heißt eben, dass es so ein Spektrum am Saum, das gerade noch Verbotenen gibt. Und dass es im Einzelfall nicht so leicht ist, da eine Grenze zu ziehen. Wer ist denn jetzt eigentlich Nazi, der ausgegrenzt werden muss und wer nicht? Und das führt dazu, dass eben auch, ich will nicht sagen, Unschuldige, aber Leute, die es eigentlich nicht verdient haben, mit ausgegrenzt werden, was zu einer Verstärkung der Fronten führt. Also der Graben zwischen den Ideologien wird größer durch diese selbst verstärkenden Effekte. Wir haben auf der einen Seite dieses Echo-Kammer-Ding, dass jeder Idiot heute Leute findet, die auch seine Idiotie teilen und dann durch den Echo-Kammer-Effekt verstärkt sich das selbst und es bildet sich das Selbstbewusstsein raus, dass man im Recht ist. Und da gibt es ja diesen schönen Spruch, the road to hell is paved with good intentions. Die schlimmsten Schäden in der Weltgeschichte sind nie von irgendwelchen kaputten Einzeltätern gemacht worden, sondern immer von Leuten, die glaubten, sie seien im Recht.
Ja, und es tun es gut und das Richtige.
Sie tun für das Größere gut. Ja, das ist immer das Argument, mit dem die furchtbaren Sachen begründet werden. Und ich finde deswegen auch diese Idee, dass man die Leute ausgrenzen muss, schlecht. Ja, weil dann haben die nämlich überhaupt keine Gegenstimmen mehr, die den Nachwuchs abzwängen können. Wenn jetzt irgendein rebellierender Jugendlicher von linken Eltern in seiner Rebellenphase zu den Nazis geht und wir haben den einfach in der Sekunde ausgegrenzt, wo er anfängt, sich für das Gedankengut zu interessieren, dann steht ihm nichts mehr im Weg, dem abdriften. Man muss dafür sorgen, dass jedem es offen steht, den vollen Diskurs wahrzunehmen und man muss es als wertbegreifen, die volle Breite des Diskurses zu sehen. Und das gilt eben auch nicht nur für die, sondern auch für uns. Ja, dadurch, dass wir die ausgegrenzt haben über Jahre, das ist jetzt meine These, Frank teilt die, glaube ich, nicht. Dadurch, dass wir die Nazis so lange ausgegrenzt haben, sind uns eben auch Informationen verloren gegangen. Wie viel es überhaupt gibt davon, wie stark die Organisationen sind, wie gut die vernetzt sind. Und jetzt sind wir plötzlich alle überrascht. Wo kommen denn die ganzen Nazis her?
Das stimmt so nicht.
Moment, lass mich kurz eine Formel nennen. Der andere Aspekt daran ist, dass man, also ich bin jetzt mal hypothetisch gesprochen, das stimmt glaube ich nicht in der Realität, aber damit ihr nachvollzieht, wo ich hin will. Wenn man vorher bundesweit 1% Nazis hat und dann mit dem Ausgrenzen anfängt, dann treibt man die zusammen und dann gibt es irgendwann Gegenden, wo die 30% haben. Und dafür hat man anderswo keine Nazis. Und das ist aber genau, was du nicht haben willst. Du willst ja gerade, dass die schön verteilt sind, damit sie nicht so mächtig sind.
Also zwei Punkte dagegen. Ja. Punkt eins, wie stark die Nazis sind, wie organisiert die sind und so weiter und so fort. Also wirklich die Nazis, wo man also jetzt nicht irgendwie einen... Verhandeln kann. Ja, wo man halt nicht verhandeln kann, genau. Das ist bekannt. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass das halt irgendwie, also die Antifa, bei aller Kritik, die man daran an denen üben kann, da sind die wirklich gut. Also das ist nicht so, das ist nur so, dass der Staat das halt nicht sehen wollte. Also es ist schon so, dass die sehr gut dokumentiert ist, dass die Organisation gut dokumentiert ist, dass klar ist, wer das ist, wie viele Leute dahingehen.
War das auch öffentlich oder war das so?
Ja, nein, also tatsächlich ist da genug öffentlich. Es ist halt auch nicht so, dass der Verfassungsschutz da... Also die nicht finanziert hätte. Genau. Also dieses Huch, da sind ja plötzlich Nazis, ist absoluter Quatsch. Das stimmt einfach nicht. Bei einem zweiten Punkt, was das Ausgrenzen angeht, ist es halt so, das funktioniert halt eben nicht mehr, wenn es das Internet gibt und sonstige moderne Kommunikationsmittel, weil die sich dann halt zusammenfinden. Irgendwie die einen Prozent hier und die zwei Prozent da, die finden sich dann halt irgendwie zusammen und rotten sich dann halt zusammen und machen ihr Ding so. Mein Kritikpunkt an diesem Ausgrenzen schließt schon ein bisschen an an dem, was du sagst. Wenn du sagst, du hast einen Jugendlichen, der halt sich gerade orientieren muss und dann halt bei denen landet, der ist ja nur ein Fall davon. Andere sind halt Leute, die sind halt in ihrem Kern und Wesen vielleicht einfach nicht wirklich nicht rassistisch, sondern die haben halt einfach nur Angst um ihren sozio-konomischen Status. So und die sind, das ist jetzt nicht so, also ich hab ja mit mit Pegadisten rauf und drunter geredet, wenn ich die mal getroffen habe, um einfach zu verstehen, wie so ticken. Und es sind die meisten von denen haben halt eigentlich nur eine Stabilitätsangst. Ja, also die sind halt, also gibt da, klar gibt da richtige Hardcore-Assisten, wo man, wie du schon sagst, nicht mehr wandeln kann. Aber gibt da einfach eine Menge Leute, die sind, haben einfach nur Angst. Also die haben Angst davor, dass sich Dinge verändern, dass es noch schlechter wird. Die haben die Erfahrung gemacht, dass es in der Regel nicht besser wird. So und dass halt einfach auch der Umgang des Status mit solchen Problemsituationen nicht adäquat ist. Dass halt irgendwie ihre empfundene Angst, was jetzt irgendwie sei es halt irgendwie, dass sie irgendwie in Klassen ihre Kinder in Klassen schicken müssen, wo es halt eigentlich im Wesentlichen nur noch irgendwie Kinder gibt von Migranten. Und die sagen, ok, da komme ich nicht mit klar, das ist halt nicht meine Kultur. So und wenn man denen dann sagt, du musst jetzt aber damit klarkommen, so ist es halt, dann redet man halt nicht mit denen. Also da findet halt keine Debatte statt. Da findet halt auch keine Auseinandersetzung inhaltlicher Art mehr statt, weil es eben ein gesellschaftliches Dogma gibt, zu sagen so, das ist halt so und das ist gut. Und diese Leute fühlen sich davon halt nicht mehr erfasst vom Diskurs. Dieses ganze Lügenpresse-Ding kommt ja halt auch genau daher, dass die sagen, okay, ja, aber aus meinen Informationsmedien im Internet habe ich halt irgendwie Dutzende Fälle von irgendwie Kriminalität von Migranten, habe ich halt irgendwie Auseinandersetzungen, Flüchtlingslager und so weiter und so fort. Und das sind im Zweifel möglicherweise anekdotische Einzelfälle, möglicherweise sind sie statistisch relevant.
Aber von Leuten, die man eben auch für vertrauenswert hält.
Genau, aber es sind halt die, die sie für vertrauenswert halten. Und da landen sie dann halt irgendwie bei den ganzen Fringe-Minuten. Und man sollte halt auch nicht unterschätzen, wie groß die mittlerweile sind. Also wenn man sich halt mal anguckt, Kopferlack zum Beispiel oder auch die Klickzahlen bei AT Deutsch, das sind halt tatsächlich richtig viele Leute.
Ist das veröffentlicht irgendwo?
Na du siehst das halt immer bei den Videos. Und Kop sagt auch, wie viele Bücher sie verkaufen. Und das ist halt jetzt nicht French. Also das kann man eigentlich nicht mehr so sagen. Deshalb sind halt schon, also ich würde sagen, wenn ich jetzt mal so aus dem Bauch sagen müsste, so irgendwie AfD, Pegida, Nazi-Publikum, reden wir halt schon so von 20, 25 Prozent irgendwie der Bevölkerung im waafigen Alter. Und das ist halt eine Sache, da kann man mit Ausgrenzung möglicherweise einfach nicht mehr richtig operieren, sondern da muss man einfach sich der gesellschaftlichen Debatte stellen.
Ich habe ein paar Punkte dazu. Erstens ist ja eine meiner Thesen, dass die Ausgrenzung schuld ist daran, dass es so ist wie heute. Ich will nicht bestreiten, dass das im Einzelfall wie ein valides Mittel aussieht. Aber ich möchte mal aus gründendes Erkenntnis gewinnt, die Perspektive ändern. Wir gucken jetzt mal aus Seiten andersrum drauf. Eine Sache, die mir bei diesen Pegida-Interviews im Fernsehen immer aufgefallen ist, ist, dass die dann auf Aspekte angesprochen wurden, über die sie sich offensichtlich noch keine Meinung gebildet haben. Und dann haben sie aber aus Gruppendruck, so jetzt laufe ich aber hier bei Pegida mit, also muss ich dann wohl auch deren Aspekte vertreten, haben die danach eine büchene Sache in die Kamera gesagt, wo du genau gesehen hast, da hat der noch nicht über nachgedacht. Aber das ist eben dieser Echo-Kammer-Effekt, dass du dann einen Gruppendruck hast, wenn du das Gefühl hast, es gibt eine Gruppe. Und dann gibt es plötzlich auch einen Gruppendruck, eine homogene Position zu vertreten. Und das hat man denen natürlich dann zum Strick gemacht. Aber gut, das Erste, das Zweite ist, dieses Zusammenrotten über das Internet, was du hier gerade als Nachteil beschreibst, das ist auf der anderen Seite ja auch die Erweckungsbotschaft des Internets. Das ist ja ein Heilsversprechen.
Nein, das war das Heilsversprechen.
Das war unser großes Heilsversprechen, dass wir gesagt haben, so was wie den CCC gibt es überhaupt in der Größe nur wegen dem Internet. Weil sich jetzt plötzlich eben Leute, die ganzen ausgegrenzten Nerds, haben sich halt zusammengefunden. Also wir müssen hier ein bisschen die moralische Betrachtung aus mehreren Blickwinkeln vornehmen und nicht nur einfach sagen, dass das generell scheiße ist.
Das ist kein moralisches Argument. Das ist nur eine reine phenomenologische Betrachtung.
Bei dir weiß ich das, aber ich möchte gern, weil ich genau weiß, wie die Leute das aufnehmen werden.
Also ich will nur mal betonen, das ist kein moralisches Argument. Das ist halt nur eine rein phenomenologische Betrachtung.
Man muss sich einfach überlegen, dass wir aus der anderen Seite gesehen, dass natürlich auch große Werkzeuge fürs Gute sind und nicht nur fürs Böse. Aber das heißt eben, hier haben wir schon wieder die Folgenabscheidung nicht gemacht, was ja so ein häufiges Ding ist. Ja, das hätte man ja auch vorher sehen können, dass die Nazis unsere Mittel gegen uns anwenden.
Ja gut, ich meine, an irgendeinem Punkt hätte man es sehen können, aber ich glaube, dass der...
Hätte an der Entscheidung nichts geändert, wahrscheinlich.
Nee, es hat an der Entscheidung nichts geändert, weil die Vorteile so stark überwiegen bisher. Aber die Frage...
Warte mal, einen Punkt noch. Dieses, was ich jetzt als Echo-Kammer bezeichne, abwertend bei denen, die anderer Meinung sind als ich, wenn ich das aus deren Sicht betrachte, ist unsere Presse in der Echo-Kammer. Weil die achten an, es sind auch eine Gruppe, es gibt auch Gruppendruck, die schreiben alle dasselbe, was der Spiegel schreibt. Auch da gibt es diese Homogenitätsgeschichte und die wiegeln sich gegenseitig aus. Es gibt noch so Versuche, Pluralität zu simulieren, zwischendurch. Aber so aus Sicht eines desjenigen, der jetzt Lügenpresse und Systemmedien oder was weiß ich, wie die Nazibegriffe da heißen, schreit, sieht die Presse genau wie so eine Echo-Kammer aus, wie aus unserer Sicht deren Informationsmedien.
Bemerkenswerterweise ändert sich das ja gerade. Also da spielt natürlich dann halt die ökonomische Situation der Verlage ein bisschen rein. Zum anderen aber natürlich auch, dass insbesondere sowas wie irgendwie Cop und Konsorten gezeigt haben, dass es da halt irgendwie einen Marktpotential gibt. Weil anders kann ich mir halt zum Beispiel auch nicht erklären, wieso die FAZ halt da irgendwie Jesper von Altenbock um da halt irgendwie so Amok laufen lässt. Wieso denn?
Das ist gerade eine Strategie, die sich echt verbreitet. Oder ist dann bei der Welt die Welt. Was ist denn da los?
Welt und FAZ scheinen sich da halt gerade irgendwie so ein Wettlauf nach irgendwie rechts zu liefern. In dieser Flüchtlingsdebatte.
Und angefangen hat Spiegel mit dem, wie heißt der nochmal, Fleschauer. Das war auch so ein Versuch.
Ja, beim Spiegel ist das mit dem Fleschauer ist glaube ich eher so ein, der ist da halt glaube ich der Quotentroll.
Weil, naja, das ist doch bei Welt auch so. Ich glaube nicht, dass die sich hinschauen und sagen, so jetzt wollen wir mal hier Nazi.
Na ja komm, weißt du, die haben Brote oder irgendwie wie jahrelang durchgefüttert. So das ist halt bei denen schon gehört, glaube ich eher dazu. Also das ist halt irgendwie, nee, also das meine, also was mich ja, also was ich sehr interessant fand an der Flüchtlingsgeschichte war, dass wie synchron die Bildzeitung und Merkel gekippt sind. Von, wie sagen wir, gar nichts. Wir weisen mal höchstens auf Probleme hin oder füttern mal die Pegadisten so. Bei der Bild gab es das ja häufiger so.
Gestern regen wir uns auf, dass die einzigen, die im Moment über die negativen Aspekte des Flüchtlingsproblems reden, RT Deutsch ist.
Sind nicht die einzigen, das will ich so nicht behaupten, aber das ist so, dass sonst viel in den Lokalzeitungen statt oder auf einer sehr abstrakten Ebene. Das heißt also, dass die Meldungen zum Beispiel über völlig aus dem Ruder und schiefgelaufene Hilfsgüterverteilungen, wo dann die LKWs gestürmt wurden und die abbrechen mussten, weil Verletzte gab, wo die halt einfach Leute aus Ländern zusammen in ein Lager getan haben, was sie nicht hätten tun sollen, weil dann halt Stress und Arger gibt zwischen denen, Auseinandersetzungen über irgendwie alles Mögliche. Man muss auch vergessen, die Leute sind halt traumatisiert. Die haben halt gerade irgendwie Wochen oder Monate lange Horrorreisen hinter sich.
Die müssen sich erstmal wieder gewöhnen an die Zivilisation.
Das fällt halt auch eher dünn, was Stress angeht. Aber darüber muss man halt einfach auch reden können. Das findet momentan in der Bundespresse eher abstrakt statt. Also jetzt so wie gestern der Bericht beim Spiegel aus der Telefonkonferenz der Innenminister, die gesagt haben, wir haben nichts mehr, wir können jetzt nur noch die Bundeswehr aus den Kasernen schmeißen und dann haben wir keine Betten mehr. Also auf so einer abstrakten Ebene, so eine Bot-Fol argumentationsebene. Das findet jetzt langsam statt und ich fürchte halt, ich fürchte, dass das halt irgendwann kippt.
Also ich meine nicht nur die tatsächlichen Presse, sondern ich meine auch so was wie Weiß. Weiß ist immer da, wo das Blut spritzt. Die haben so Stories wie, wir interviewen die Journalistin, die das sterbende Baby irgendwie da am Stein hat. Und die sind aber nicht bei den Flüchtlingsheimen, wo irgendwie Sachen explodieren, sondern da gibt es noch so ein Tabu. Und das betrifft eben nicht nur die großen Medien, sondern das betrifft so auch die Blogs, weil jeder Angst hat, wenn ich das anfasse, bin ich sofort der Nazi. Oder irgendwie Pegida-Sympathisant oder was. Und das ist so eine Amputation von Gewebe im Diskurs, der dazu führt, dass das Ergebnis einfach scheiße wird.
Letztendlich ist es halt so, dass man da halt einfach, wenn man eine problemorientierte Diskussion führt und sagt, also eine lösungsorientierte Diskussion, sagt, okay, das sind die Probleme, es gibt diese Erfahrungen, es gibt auch Profis, die wissen, wie man sowas managt. Warum fragen wir die nicht mal? Wir lassen uns schnell aus den Fehlern lernen, bevor noch mehr Leute die Fehler machen. Lassen uns halt dafür sorgen, dass halt irgendwie diese Erfahrungen verbreitet werden und so weiter und so fort. Dass man sich diesen Lernmechanismus, der zwingend notwendig ist, wenn wir tatsächlich mit dieser Situation als Land klarkommen wollen, und das wollen ja die meisten Leute in diesem Land glücklicherweise, dass wir diesen Lernmechanismus uns nicht amputieren, indem wir Angst haben, über Probleme zu reden. Das wäre genau falsch. Oder das Land wäre genau in derselben Falle, wie Niederlande gelandet sind, wo auch jahrelang nicht offen darüber diskutiert werden konnte, was die Probleme sind, aus Angst, dass man dann gleich Rassist ist. Statt zu sagen, okay, jetzt sind Probleme, wir lösen diese Probleme. Das hat irgendwie nichts damit zu tun, dass es in Pakistan oder in Afghanistan oder in Syrien ist. Es sei denn, es ist eine wichtige Information dafür, dass er sich mit einer anderen Völkerschaft klopft oder irgendwie sonst nicht kompatibel ist. Aber letzten Endes wollen wir die Menschen hier haben, wir wollen die willkommen heißen und wir müssen uns dem Problem stellen, wie wir das technisch umsetzen. Und dazu gehört eben auch öffentlich darüber zu diskutieren, was die Probleme sind, wie wir sie lösen.
Ich glaube ja fast ein bisschen, dass wir da anders sogar nachdenken, weil wir eben so Projektmanagement-Erfahrungen haben. Das ist einfach wie wir an Probleme rangehen. Und ich glaube, ein Großteil der Bevölkerung denkt sich, naja, das ist nicht meine Aufgabe, das macht die Regierung. Aber es führt eben dazu, wenn ich das Problem nicht verstanden habe, wird meine Lösung nicht funktionieren. Das ist einfach eine Sache. Ich habe hier als Stichwort aufgeschrieben, Filterbubble verhindert Realitätsabgleich. Das gilt in alle Richtungen. Wenn die Filterbubble der Presse mich über solche Aspekte nicht informiert, dann werden es nur irgendwelche Internet-Gruppierungen um irgendwelche Nazi-Sachen thematisiert.
Mit dem entsprechenden Spin und den entsprechenden Falschmeldungen. Genau.
Und dann irgendwann heißt es wieder die Lügenpresse. Und dann wundern sich alle. Das ist einfach ein Versagen auf einem so fundamentalen Niveau, dass ich mich frage, ob das nicht Absicht ist. Gelegentlich gibt es ja so als Strategie eine Sache offiziell zu tun, aber dann so katastrophal zu versagen, dass man nie wieder mit dem Problem konfrontiert werden wird. Ich frage mich gerade, ob das das Ziel ist, dass die sagen, wir nehmen die ganzen Früchtlinge rein und dann fährt das massiv gegen die Wand, weil wir dafür gesorgt haben, dass irgendwie die Infrastruktur scheiße ist.
Und die entsprechenden Mittel nicht bereitstehen und die Integration nicht ordentlich verbreitet und gemanagt wird.
Und dann können wir jahrelang haben wir dieses Flüchtlingsproblem nicht mehr an der Backe. Weil wir immer sagen können, erinnert euch an 2015, wollt ihr das nochmal haben? Ich bin gerade ein bisschen am überlegen, ob das gerade passiert.
Also das ist auch meine Sorge, selbst wenn das halt keine absichtliche Strategie wäre, kann trotzdem halt ein Ergebnis sein.
Kann passieren, ja.
Also meine Frage des praktischen Managements dabei, wird die Wesentliche werden. Und dazu gehört halt eben auch, dass wir über die Probleme reden und diskutieren, was irgendwie sinnvolle Lösungen sein können. Und wie man, also nicht nur auf der sozialen Ebene und der organisatorischen Ebene, sondern eben auch der finanziellen Ebene. Und irgendwie dazu gehört dann halt eben solche Sachen wie Anerkennung von Ausbildungsabschlüssen, von Möglichmachen, von Ausbildung so schnell wie möglich. Von irgendwie dem ganzen Problem, das mit den Wohnungen entsteht. Ich meine, es gibt halt ohnehin schon irgendwie Wohnungsmärkte, wo es eigentlich schon nicht mehr geht so und wo halt einfach der soziale Druck immer stärker wird. Und die Leute natürlich, wenn sie dann halt anfangen müssen, den dritten Job zu machen, um sich ihre Miete leisten zu können, dann ist halt die politische Toleranz für noch mehr Leute, die sich in demselben Wohnungsmarkt tummeln, halt irgendwie aus ganz egoistischen Aspekten gering. Und das zu verhindern, dass es soweit kommt, ist eine politische Aufgabe, die man eben nicht mit einer moralisch verdrucksenden Diskussion angehen kann. Wenn man halt nicht über Probleme reden kann, kann man sie halt auch nicht lösen.
Ja, wir sind jetzt hier ein bisschen aus unserer geplanten Zeitlinie abgewichen. Lass uns mal kurz den Übergang schaffen, indem wir hier sagen, Ausgrenzung als Gegenstrategie gab es schon vor dem Internet. Und zwar bei Stammtischen. Da können wir, glaube ich, mal drüber reden. Nämlich eigentlich ist das ja eine valide Strategie, dass man sagt, ich will jetzt hier erst mal meinen Kram soweit unter Dach und Fach bringen, dass da keine doofen Fehler drin sind. Und dazu unterhalte ich mich erst mal mit meiner Echo-Kammer. Das war früher auch so, dass man sagt, den Platz an dem Stammtisch hier musst du dir verdienen, indem du grob diese Mindestanforderungen genügst. Und das ist dann eben nicht nur Verhalten, sondern auch an diesen Punkten unserer Meinung sein.
Das hat natürlich einen Grund in dem Sinne, dass du damit vermeidest, dass du nicht vorankommst. Ja, also insbesondere bei Diskussionen, wo du eine relativ schwierige fachliche Ausgangsbasis hast, wo man halt versuchen muss, erst mal relativ viel zu verstehen. Also was ich jetzt mit dir über Colonel Scheduling diskutieren wollen würde, da würdest du sagen, komm lass mal.
Da muss man alles erklären.
Klar kann man alles erklären, aber ich müsste mich halt da erstmal eine Weile hinsetzen und ziemlich viele Dinge verstehen. Und vorher würdest du nicht ernsthaft mit mir über die vorderen Nachteile von diesem oder jedem Scheduler diskutieren wollen würden.
Naja, das ist eine Sache, die muss man sich erarbeiten. Also jetzt nicht inhaltlich, sondern vom Weltblick darauf. Also mein Blick ist, wenn ich das nicht immer wieder erklären kann, dann habe ich es selber nicht verstanden. Ich freue mich, wenn ich irgendwie Leuten was erklären kann, denn da merke ich erst, ob ich mich in Widersprüche verwickel oder nicht, ob ich irgendwie ein Detail nicht verstanden habe. Und es ist mir viel lieber, wenn ich das entdecke, wenn ich das jemandem erkläre, der es auch nicht verstanden hat, der merkt das dann vielleicht nicht, als wenn ich das in einem Fachgespräch mit einem Experten merke. Aber mich wundert gerade so ein bisschen diese utilitaristische Sicht. Ich hätte eher gesagt, das ist so Harmoniebedürfnis, dass man sagt, das ist einfach Stress, wenn ich da Leute habe, die nicht meiner Meinung sind. Und ich möchte mich dem Stress nicht aussetzen.
Ich denke, das hat damit auch zu tun. Aber wenn ich so überlege, warum ich Leute aus Diskussionen ausgrenze oder mit denen ich reden will, dann hat es meistens drei Gründe. Entweder ich habe gerade das Bedürfnis, mich auf einem anderen Niveau zu unterhalten, weil ich gerade das Gefühl habe, ich muss jetzt mal diesen Gedanken zu Ende entwickeln, weil da kommt, was mich weiterbringt oder was Diskussionen weiterbringt oder eine Idee, die ich jetzt nicht weiterentwickeln kann, wenn ich jetzt noch mal mich über den kleinen Scheiß auseinandersetzen muss, den ich schon vor Jahren abgehakt habe. Das kann ich total verstehen. Also das ist eine valide Punkt, zu sagen so, tut mir leid, bei diesem Spiel kannst du jetzt gerade zu diesem Zeitpunkt nicht mitspielen, weil dir fehlt zu viel Voraussetzung. Das ist das eine. Das andere ist, wenn Leute möglicherweise fachlich oder inhaltlich auf demselben Niveau spielen, aber aus ideologischen Gründen eine völlig andere Meinung sind. Also zu sagen, sie kennen alle die selben Fakten und wir sind uns darüber einig, dass wir uns einfach nicht einig sind. Dann kann das sehr produktiv sein oder auch nicht, je nachdem wie die Leute drauf sind. Das ist eben genau dieser Stressfaktor mit diesem, wenn die Leute dann nervig auf ihrem Standpunkt beharren, der möglicherweise valide ist, aber mich gerade nicht voranbringt.
Also ich persönlich ziehe die Linie, wenn irgendwie Vorwürfe im Raum stehen.
Gut, wenn jemand atominem geht, dann ist es halt vorbei. Also dann hab ich halt irgendwie auch keinen, dann brauch ich dann nicht weitermachen. Das ist dann halt irgendwie...
Dann geht es nicht um inhaltliche Führungen, sondern um Angriffe und das ist dann auch bei mir Schluss.
Gut, ich meine, das kann ich halt auch spielen, klar. Ich meine natürlich irgendwie...
Hat man auch gelegentlich Lust zu...
Wenn jemand irgendwie möchte, dann unbedingt möchte, dann kann ich auch irgendwie die flammende Streitachse auspacken. Das wird dann meistens ein bisschen hässlich, aber das bringt uns halt nicht voran. Das ist dann halt mehr so Sport, was viele Leute auch nicht verstehen. Ich glaube, das sollten wir nochmal erklären. Die Sachen mit dem Usen...
Ja, wir haben die Usen, die Usen müssen wir nochmal in Ruhe erklären, weil das nämlich viele Sachen in ein Licht rückt, die der Erkenntnis dienen können. Also das Usen ist eine, ist glaube ich, weiß gar nicht, ob es älter als E-Mail ist. Also ist jedenfalls eine steinalte...
Das Usen ist richtig alt, ja....
ist eine steinalte Geschichte aus den absoluten Anfangstagen des Internets. Und zwar haben sich da News Server gegenseitig den Bestand an irgendwelchen Foren miteinander abgeglichen. Also heute kennt man ja so Webforen.
So Reddit ist das größte hier.
Ja und früher war das so, dass es einen internationalen Verbund aus Servern gab, einen informellen Verbund, da konnte man sich genauso anklinken, wie man sich an Router anklingt, um das Internet selbst zu erweitern. Und dann haben die einfach alle reinkommenden Foren-Postings mit allen anderen News-Servern gesinnt. Das ging hin und her. Und das heißt eben auch, dass es keinen autoritativen irgendwie Routemaster-Server irgendwo gab. Das heißt, wenn irgendwo irgendeiner irgendwas posten wollte, dann ging es an alle Server. Und das heißt aber auch, dass es keine zentrale Stelle gibt, die sagen kann, okay, was ist jetzt, Mist, das löschen wir jetzt mal. Ja, es gibt keine Polizei, es gibt keine Polizei, es gibt keine Zensur. Alles was es gibt, alles was es gibt oder gab, das Usern gibt es immer noch, es ist nur ein Schatten seiner selbst. Alles was es gab, ist wenn es einen Konsens gab, dass man gesagt hat, okay, also zum Beispiel gibt es hier ein Forum zu Kinderpornografie, das tragen wir jetzt nicht auf unserem Server. Das konnte man machen. Aber dass einzelne Postings von Serverbetreibern irgendwie zensiert oder auch nur gelesen wurden, war völlig utopisch, weil das Volumen so unglaublich groß war.
Also es gab am Ende Serverseitige Blacklists, dass nicht nur Foren, also Userngruppen nicht mitkopiert wurden aus dem Feed. Und beim Einsortieren gab es, weiss ich zumindest, dass es bei einigen Servern dann tatsächlich Blacklists gab, wo Posts von einzelnen Leuten dann einfach nicht auftauchten.
Also technisch geht sowas.
Aber immer nur lokal.
Aber das ist dann nur lokal und natürlich downstream. Also wenn du irgendwie das Posting nicht siehst, kannst du es auch nicht weitergeben im Grunde. Aber das ist die absolute Ausnahme. Was es dann später gab, ist ein Inban Signaling-Protokoll, mit dem ich sagen konnte, dieses Posting war von mir, das möchte ich mal zurückziehen. Und das war aber technisch so wenig gesichert, dass man auch andere Leute Postings für sie zurückziehen konnte. Und dann gab es teilweise so Edit Wars, würde man heute sagen, dass die Leute halt immer löschen und dann wird neu gepostet. Und es haben sich viele soziale Probleme später im Internet, im Usen sehr früh gezeigt. Es gab zum Beispiel eine Gestalt namens Kibo, die dafür berühmt wurde, dass sie so eine Art Suchmaschine implementiert hat. Und der hat halt nach seinem Namen gesucht und tauchte dann in Foren auf, wo er noch nie gesehen wurde und hat genau zu dem Posting Reply geschickt, wo er ein Follow-Up-Historie geschickt, wo er erwähnt wurde. Und das war damals mind-blowing, die Leute. Also das geht, wir sind unwürdig. Und also diese viele von diesen Dynamiken, heute sagt man irgendwie, was sagt man, ego googeln oder so. Also das hat er vorhergenommen, dieses Konzept. Aber dadurch, dass es so ein anarchisches Ding war, wo jeder nur lokal irgendwie Sachen zensieren konnte. Und ich konnte auch nicht zum Server gehen. Dadurch, dass es verteilt ist, hat mein Provider einen News Server. Ja, das ist nicht so, dass ich zu Reddit gehe, sondern ich gehe bei meinem Provider zu deren News Server und der hat alle Foren ursprünglich. Das hat sich dann schnell gegeben, weil es nämlich auch eine, es gab zu viele Foren und es gab vor allem Foren, wo die Leute Binary's gepostet haben. Und das waren am Anfang irgendwelche, wie immer auf solchen Sachen, irgendwelche Reisefotos und dann wurden es irgendwelche Porno-Fotos und dann wurden es irgendwelche Filme und dann wurden es Raubkopien von irgendwelchen größeren Geschichten und wir reden hier vom Volumen von Terabytes pro Tag. Und da haben man einfach viele, viele kleinere Provider gesagt, ne, das haben wir nicht. Und dann gab es irgendwann so eine Bewegung, dass es kommerzielle Usenet-Provider gab und das bei den Providern inzwischen weitgehend aufgehört hat, dass es überhaupt noch News Server gibt. Und die haben dann tatsächlich den vollen Feed. Aber ich als End-User habe überhaupt keine Handhabe, um zu sagen, diese Posting da ist scheiße, das muss weg. Ja, ich kann jetzt entweder anfangen, Fremdcancen zu machen. Das ist aber sozial sehr angrüchig.
Eigentlich geächtet gewesen.
Ist geächtet und das ist ja auch gut so.
Ja.
Oder ich konnte in meinem Client sagen, also in meinem Leseprogramm, der Typ labert nur Scheiße, von dem will ich nie wieder Postings sehen.
Genau, den will ich nicht sehen.
Die sind aber nicht weg, sondern ich sehe die dann nur nicht mehr. Und wenn jemand darauf ein Follow-Up macht, sehe ich aber die Follow-Ups und sehe, was der mitquotet. Das heißt, man konnte dem nur dann völlig aus dem Weg gehen, wenn alle das ignoriert haben. Und das hat nie geklappt. Und es ist wie heute auf Twitter, heute gibt es ja auch einen Großteil des Neues auf Twitter, sind ja Leute, die sich gegenseitig erzählen, sie sollen endlich mal aufhören, irgendwie diesen Typen dazu zu retweeten, weil dann funktioniert mein lokaler Filter nicht mehr. Also die sozialen Probleme hat das Usenet alle um mehrere Dekaden früher gehabt als der Rest der Welt.
Und einer der Spezialitäten, die im Usenet schon sehr früh auftauchten, waren halt die Flame Wars.
Na klar, das ist halt ein menschliches Phänomen.
Wo man dann halt... Also die...
Kontroverse Sachen ziehen andere kontroverse Posten nach sich.
Wobei, also ich hab neulich mal wieder so ein paar alte Usenet-Postings gelesen, also so ein paar epische Flame Wars, um mal einen Vergleich zu ziehen zu so diesen Twitter Shitstorm und Facebook Shitstorm-Nummern. Und tatsächlich ist es so, dass der das intellektuelle Niveau im Usenet, muss man leider einfach mal so sagen. Wenn halt da irgendwie so, also selbst bei den wirklich bitteren, bis aufs Blut irgendwie, und wir rufen jetzt die Polizei Flame Wars, ähm, war...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, man ruft nicht die Polizei, man ruft den taktischen Kleidenbus. Ja, das war damals das Gefühl geworden.
In den deutschen Fokuss, ja genau, war die, war einfach höher. Also man hat zumindest, selbst wenn die Leute irgendwie harte Atomminen imgegangen sind und irgendwie den, den, äh, ja ich hab auch ein paar alte Post-Exfolien gefunden.
Ja, aber es ist schön, es ist kein Vergleich zu dem Niveau heute. Ich glaub, es sind einfach zu viele Leute, die diese, diese Sozialisierung einfach brauchen könnten.
Ja, also vor allen Dingen verstehen, dass, dass man aus dieser, sich hinterher trotzdem ja noch lieb haben kann.
Ja, also dass man sich nicht lieb haben kann. Naja, aber zumindest halt irgendwie, man kann miteinander reden. Man kann trotzdem ein Bierchen trinken gehen, selbst wenn man sich vorher übel beschimpft hat.
Oder halt irgendwie, also, das gab es ja auch frequent, dass die Leute in irgendwie einer, äh, Punkt-Sorggruppe, also über irgendein Social-Issue völlig hart die Birne eingeschlagen und sich beschimpft haben und nebenan halt irgendwie in irgendeinem Tech-Forum halt irgendwie völlig friedlich sich trotzdem noch unterhalten haben. Und das vermisse ich zum Beispiel halt auch an diesen Social-Media-Dingen, weil da ist halt dieser Effekt, dass es halt immer gleich alles persönlich ist.
Ich glaube, dass es an diesen expliziten Gruppen, Newsgroups gelegen hat. Da haben sich dann keine Untergruppen gebildet. Sondern es gab häufiger Diskussionen, das gehört hier aber nicht rein. Und dann hat man denen gesagt, mach doch deine eigene Newsgroup. Was technisch zwar gegangen wäre, aber das ist also ein Abhilf-Battle, würde ich mal sagen. Das ist nicht so einfach gewesen. Es gab auch Leute, die es gemacht haben, das kam auch vor. Sogar im deutschen Usenet gab es gelegentlich Untergründungen. Ja, aber das war so eine Sache. Irgendwie zwei Newsgroups in mir, oder so.
Ja, also es ist jetzt kein Newsgroups, ja.
Das ist jetzt kein Ding. Aber so dadurch, durch diesen extern aufgedrückten, das hier sind die Gruppen-Dings. Das hier ist die Newsgroup, bei der es um irgendwie Elm als Mailklein geht. Und dann war klar, wer hier über andere Sachen als Elm redet, ist ein doof Mann. Und da gab es dann auch inhaltlich nichts zu diskutieren. Aber durch diese Zwänge, dass man einfach weiß, ich kann den zwar lokal ausblenden, aber der ist noch da. Und es wird immer Leute geben, die dieselben blöden Fragen stellen. Und die kann ich jetzt alle beschimpfen. Aber das ist zeitverschwendung, weil dann kommen andere Leute. Daraus haben sich so ein paar Lösungswege ergeben, die ich heute immer noch für bahnbrechend halte und von denen ich mir wünschen würde, dass da mehr von gibt. Man hat nämlich gesagt einfach, okay, wir machen jetzt eine FAQ. Frequently Asked Questions. Das ist einfach eine Liste von Fragen, die immer wieder kommen und den Antworten, die auch immer wieder kommen. Und dann nimmt man sich ein bisschen Zeit und formuliert die Antworten so, dass sie auch wirklich alles beantworten, damit nicht die nächste blöde Frage gleich kommt. Und der zusammenhängende Nenner war, keine Frage ist zu blöde, als dass sie nicht in die FAQ kommen kann.
Wenn sie in das Topic passt.
Ich gebe mal ein Beispiel. Es gab Comp.com-Pression. Das ging um Datenkompressionsverfahren, sowas wie ZIP. Und da war eine Frage in der FAQ. Ich habe hier dieses Programm gesehen, das behauptet, es kann alles mindestens um N% reduzieren. Ist das nicht toll? Ja, und da kann man jetzt sagen, das ist offensichtlich Bullshit. Denn wenn das ginge, würde ich das immer auf sich selbst anwenden. Und dann kommt irgendwann Null byte raus. Genau diese Antwort steht in der FAQ. Und da kann man jetzt sagen, wer so blöde ist, dass er das nicht selber kapiert, der hat in dieser Nussgruppe nichts verloren. Hat man aber nicht gesagt, weil es nichts bringt. Man kann auf egal, wie gerecht der Zorn ist, den man auf diese Leute entwickelt, es gibt unendlich viele davon. Und jeden September machen die Unis das nächste, das neue Semester auf und es kommt ein neuer Schwung. Und das ist ein Kampf, den du nicht gewinnen kannst. Einzig, was du machen kannst, ist, die einfach da abzuholen, wo sie sind. Und beschimpfen bringt nichts. Ja, und diese Erkenntnis ist so wichtig für alle. Für alle Kommunikationsstrukturen, dass einfach beschimpfen sinnlos ist. Der Einzige, der was verliert, ist der Beschimpfende. Keiner gewinnt was und der einzige Verlierer ist der Beschimpfende, weil der hat sich entblößt als Vollidiot.
Ich habe tatsächlich auch mal einen Newsgroup eingerichtet.
Ach, echt?
Über viele Jahre. Alt-Jokes-Pension. Damals, wo es mal zur Erklärung gesagt wurde, da hatte Intel ein paar sehr peinliche Fehler in den Penzio-Prozessionen. Da gab es eine Menge Witze darum. Und es waren so viele, dass es dann irgendwann notwendig war, irgendwie einen Newsgroup dazu zu bauen. Die gab es für viele Jahre, ich glaube irgendwann vor zwei oder drei Jahren wurde sie gekillt. Ach ja, naja, aber die interessante Frage ist ja...
Warte mal, eine Sache will ich noch prägnant rausformulieren. Probleme ignorieren, löst sie nicht. Wenn ich die Leute ausblende, sind die trotzdem da. Und das ist eine Sache, die ich glaube, meinen Blick auf den Rest der Welt bis heute prägt.
Ja, andererseits ist es natürlich so, dass der... Also ich glaube, dass man...
Da wolltest du gegenreden, glaube ich.
Dass man, genau, dass man, naja, dass man sich überlegen muss, bzw. vielleicht sogar auch einfach offen deklarieren muss, welchen Zweck ein Kommunikationsforum hat. Man sagt, okay, hier in diesem Forum wollen wir wirklich mit allen reden. Also auch wenn sie Meinungen haben, die nicht unseren Meinungen entsprechen, die, wenn wir, also hier reden wir auch im Zweifel mit Nazis oder wir versuchen zumindest mit ihnen zu argumentieren und sind halt irgendwie willens, halt irgendwie auch das Argument zum 50. Mal aus der FAQ zu kopieren, versus Foren oder wie auch immer Kommunikationswege, Kommunikationsstrukturen, wo man sagt, okay, pass auf, hier wollen wir unter uns sein, hier möchte ich selber Strategie entwickeln, hier möchte ich irgendwie Gedanken fassen, hier möchte ich irgendwie mich mit mehr oder minder Gleichgesinnten unterhalten, um, sagen wir mal, intellektuell weiterzukommen. Und ich glaube, eines der Probleme ist, dass genau diese Trennung in den sozialen Medien nicht existiert. Und wenn, dann ist sie höchstens implizit angenommen. Also die Leute nehmen an, in meinem Twitter-Feed will ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Das ist mein Wohnzimmer, das soll dir herangehen.
Will ich halt mich nicht mit irgendwie Leuten auseinandersetzen, die halt doof sind. Oder in meinem Blog, in meinen Blogkommentaren oder wo auch immer, was auch immer das Forum ist. Und ich glaube, es ist extrem viel helfen würde, einfach das explizit zu deklarieren. Und zu sagen, pass auf, das ist hier ein offenes Forum, nehmen wir mal Facebook oder was auch immer. Eine Facebook-Gruppe ist halt eben nicht offen, sondern ist halt eine geschlossene Angelegenheit, wo man sich halt irgendwie nur mit ein paar Leuten unterhalten will. Oder ist eben tatsächlich was, wo man sagt, okay, hier versucht man auch Leute abzuholen, die zum Beispiel, nehmen wir mal wieder das Nazi-Beispiel, die halt möglicherweise einfach noch nicht wirklich Nazi sind, sondern halt einfach nur Sorge haben und die halt einfach irgendwie, keine Ahnung, in NPD-Propaganda gelesen haben oder Propaganda von der AfD oder wem auch immer. Und das nicht so verkehrt finden und einfach Fragen stellen darüber, ist dann das nicht vielleicht so und irgendwie wird das nicht eigentlich eine ganz gute Lösung, was die da vorschlagen. Und die möglicherweise auch noch offen dafür sind, dass man erklärt, okay, pass auf, das ist vielleicht nicht das Problem. Das Problem sind vielleicht nicht die Ausländer, sondern das Problem ist vielleicht einfach die Verteilung des Geldes in diesem Land.
Wobei das ist ja auch schon wieder.
Um mal ein sehr plattes Beispiel zu wählen. Ich glaube, dass eben dieser Mangel an Foren, wo die Leute abgeholt werden, jeder sozialen Bewegung gerade auf dem Fußfeld, sowohl im Feminismus als auch der Flüchtlingsbewegung, also überall sehen wir das. Und ich glaube, das ist genau das selbe Spiel, haben wir auch in der Überwachungsdebatte. Auch da haben wir genau das Problem. Ich muss mich halt irgendwie mit Leuten darüber streiten, wie ich so ein FAZ schreibe. Weil natürlich da auch irgendwie so Leute wie Jasper von Altenbock umschreiben, die halt irgendwie, naja, da brauchen wir nicht groß drüber reden. Natürlich möchte ich aber eigentlich auch Menschen erreichen, die halt nicht schon meiner Meinung sind. So und die, die halt gerade, genau, gerade die will ich halt eben erreichen. Deswegen muss ich mich halt eben auch auf Territorien begeben, wo ich eben nicht ideologisch rein bin, wo halt einfach die eben auch Leute unterwegs sind, die halt irgendwie anders sind. Und das ist halt, das finde ich halt eine sehr grundlegende Angelegenheit, dass wir erkennen, dass Ausgrenzung nicht die einzige Strategie ist, sondern Ausgrenzung ist ein Mittel, was wir sehr bewusst in Einzelfällen, in klar definiertem Umfang einsetzen können. Wenn wir erkennen, okay, bei denen ist sowieso nichts mehr zu holen oder bei den Leuten, dann da gibt es halt sowieso nichts mit zu retten. Aber das ist eine Sache, die ich sehr vorsichtig betreiben muss. Ich meine, bevor ich halt Leute mit dem Bannhammer belege oder vorhin oder sonst irgendwas mit dem Bannhammer belege, will ich also teils sie aus meiner Realität ausblende oder dafür sorge, dass sie nicht mehr von mir wahrgenommen werden und auch meine Freunde möglicherweise auffordere, dass sie nicht mehr wahrgenommen werden, weil ich dafür einen verdammt guten Rund haben.
Also es gibt im Newsnet so einen Begriff namens Lurker, den gibt es ja auch heute noch in Foren. Das ist einfach jemand, der an der Diskussion nur passiv teilnimmt. Der geht halt hin und liest alles und schreibt aber nichts.
Oder wenn einmal im Jahr oder sowas.
Oder vielleicht einmal im Jahr, genau. Und ich kann sagen, aus meiner Vergangenheit im Newsnet, dass ich mir eine Freude daraus gemacht habe, die mir aus irgendwelchen Newsgroups erschienen, die mir nicht völlig uninteressant erschienen, einfach die FAQ zu holen. Und es gab da einen zentralen Server an einer Uni, wo die alle rum lagen. Und es gab auch eine Newsgroup, wo die immer gepostet wurden. Verschiedene, ja, also ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr, wo das war. Aber diese ganzen FAQs gibt es immer noch irgendwo. Die kann man finden, wenn man die sucht. Die meisten sind halt stein alt. Aber ich glaube, man könnte einfach so viel Einnordung von Newbies in irgendwelchen sozialen Gruppierungen wegoptimieren, automatisieren, indem man einfach ein FAQ hat und die hängt an der Wand. Ja. Und wer reinkommt, sieht die. Und ich glaube, wenn wir so eine Nazi FAQ hätten, die einfach dieses Gedankengut mal aufschreibt und kein Statement zu blöde. Kein Statement zu blöde. Je blöder das Statement, desto wichtiger, dass man kohärent formuliert, warum es falsch ist. Nicht warum es blöde ist, sondern warum es falsch ist. Denn wenn die Leute das nicht äußern müssen und dann haha bist du ein Vollidiot entgegenkriegen, sondern das von Computer passiv aus ihrem Gedächtnis gestrichen kriegen können, dann haben wir uns viel Hager erspart.
Dann müsste ihre Argumente gechallenged werden.
Ja, ich glaube, das müsste mal jemand machen. Und am besten gar nicht so irgendwie strikt Frage, Antwort, sondern irgendwie Statement. Und dann gibt es folgende Wege, wie man das betrachten kann und die dann halt die Abwägung dem jeweiligen Typen überlassen.
Interessanterweise machen die Rechten das ja. Also die haben so Argumentations-Guidelines. Also das gibt da halt so eine Gruppe, die ursprünglich aus dem französischen Raum kommt. Ach so, so eine...
Nein, aber das ist ja noch ein bisschen was anderes.
Migrationsfeindliche Gruppen. Die sind die sogenannten Identitären. Das ist halt so eine... Die verfolgen halt diesen sogenannten Ethnopluralismus. Also die sagen halt nicht, wir sind Rassisten, sondern wir sagen, wir finden es gut, dass es viele Völker auf diesem Planeten gibt. Wir finden es nur gut, wenn jedes Volk da bleibt, wo es ist. So, das ist halt so deren...
Ich bin kein Rassist, aber... Die sollen mal bleiben, wo sie herkommen.
Genau. So, das ist halt so... Super. Und ist natürlich noch ein bisschen elaborierter formuliert. Und die arbeiten tatsächlich mit so ein Argumentationsguidelines, in denen sie sagen, okay, das hier ist die These, die mir entgegengestellt wird von irgendwie den Verfechtern in einer multikulturellen oder wie auch immer Gesellschaft. Warum ist die denn falsch? Was ist denn daran so? Und wenn du das liest, das ist teilweise richtig...
Überzeugend.
Na gut, das überzeugt mich jetzt nicht.
Nicht dich, aber es ist halt... Du liest sie jetzt durch und kannst verstehen, wenn sich da jemand von überzeugen lässt.
Genau. Und die arbeiten halt eben auf diesem Niveau. Also die arbeiten und sagen halt, okay, uns ist das nicht so blöd, sondern wir holen die Leute da ab, wo sie sind. Wir holen die Leute bei ihren Zweifeln ab, bei ihren...
Anders geht es auch nicht.
Anders geht es nicht. Und daraus hat genau diese Kohärenz in der Argumentation und in der Strategie fehlt der Linken halt, weil die halt immer momentan auf diesem moralischen Empörungstrip ist. Also auf diesem, die einfach von vorne rein annimmt, dass jeder, der sich mit solchen Gedanken rumschlägt, erst mal per se Nazi ist. Und wenn er Nazi ist, müssen wir nicht mit ihm reden.
Es gibt auch so internen Ausgrenzungsgeschichten bei den Linken viel. Gar nicht mal nur gegenüber den Nazis, sondern auch so, du bist aber kein echter Linker. Du bist aber so ein Salonkommunist, oder was man da für... Ja, du magst ja irgendwie hier und da, aber so... Bei den Nazis würde man sagen, okay, wir sind hier und da derselben Meinung, dann können wir doch was zusammen machen. Und bei den Linken heißt es, wir sind hier unter einer Meinung, aber da drüben nicht. Nee, du bist ein Idiot. Daraus ergeben sich dann so Sachen, wo ich mich jedes Mal frage, was sind das eigentlich für Leute? Zum Beispiel hat neulich irgendein Prolet getwittert, der Nazi-Versteher, Fefe, blablabla blub blub. Und da dachte ich mir so in einem Land, wo Bildungsbürger und Gutmensch irgendwie Schimpfworte sind, bin ich dann auch gern irgendwie Nazi-Versteher. Ja, so was soll denn das, ja? Seit wann ist Verstehen was Schlechtes? Hallo? Geht's noch? Und diese Idee, dass man sich Sachen gar nicht anhören darf, da denk ich mir immer, das kann ich nur in mein Weltbild bringen, wenn ich Angst habe, dass mich das überzeugen könnte.
Wenn man sich tief drin eben doch nicht sicher ist, ne?
Und da denk ich mir so, sind die so ungefestigt in ihren Strukturen, dass sie denken, wenn man den Nazis irgendwie einen Spalt breit sich zumindest anhört, was deren Problem gerade ist, dass man dann irgendwie überzeugt werden könnte, oder was? Hallo?
Na ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich, also gerade in dieser, auch in Teil dieser Critical-Whiteness-Geschichte, also diese sozusagen Anti-Rassismus-3.0-Nummer, resultiert ja eben auch daraus, dass die Leute versuchen, nicht aktiv damit umzugehen, dass sie halt irgendwie möglicherweise rassistische Grundgefühle haben, oder dass sie halt Misstrauen gegenüber Leuten haben, die eine andere Hautfarbe als sie haben oder was auch immer, und zu versuchen zu verstehen, woher das kommt und irgendwie damit umzugehen und zu sagen, okay, vielleicht ist es halt so, dass ich diese Misstrauen habe, aber das heißt jetzt nicht, dass ich das halt irgendwie ausagieren muss oder dem irgendwie auf den Grund gehen und versuchen, das irgendwie anders zu lösen, so. Sondern das wird dann halt ideologisch überlagert.
Ich kann es ja auch nie loswerden, wenn ich mich damit beschäftige, wenn ich es dann habe.
Wenn du mich nicht beschäftigst.
Ja, ich muss mich damit beschäftigen, um zu verstehen. Und wenn ich verstanden habe, warum ich das habe, kann ich plötzlich sehen, warum diese anderen Leute sich davon ins Nazi-Lager treiben lassen. Und dann kann ich nämlich mit denen reden und denen sagen, pass mal auf, hier ist ein anderer Ausweg.
Ja. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch so ein Punkt, dass ideologische Überlagerung funktioniert halt nicht. Also da bin ich vielleicht auch als Aussie ein bisschen sensibilisierter, weil ich da halt einfach sozusagen die First-Hand-Erfahrung habe, dass es funktioniert halt einfach nicht mit dem ideologischen Beschluss von moralischem Hörwertigsein zu versuchen, irgendwie die Realität zu übertünchen. Und stattdessen muss man halt hingehen und sagen, okay, ich hab halt ein Ideal und dieses Ideal, dem möchte ich folgen. Und auf dem Weg zu diesem Ideal muss ich Probleme lösen. Und um diese Probleme zu lösen, muss ich sie anerkennen, muss mich damit irgendwie auseinandersetzen und halt irgendwie realistische Wege finden, irgendwie sie zu lösen und mich dem zu stellen. So und die Schwierigkeit, also die ich da an vielen Stellen sehe, ist eben, dass es diesen selbst verstärkenden Mechanismus gibt, dass die Leute den moralischen Impetus als Leitbild nehmen. Also sagen, okay, du bist ein dover Rassist oder du bist irgendwie ein dover Frauenfeind, wenn du dieses Wort benutzt oder wenn du irgendwie eine dies oder jem Meinung hast oder wenn du noch nicht verstanden hast, dass jetzt halt irgendwie Social Justice Warrior ein Schimpfwort ist oder zwischendurch mal wieder nicht ein Schimpfwort war und jetzt doch wieder ein Schimpfwort ist oder was auch immer.
Ich finde das völlig wurscht, ob das ein Schimpfwort ist oder nicht. Das sind Ausweichmechanismen, um sich mit dem eigentlichen Problem nicht beschäftigen zu müssen.
Und vor allen Dingen eben nicht mehr eine Debatte zu führen, sondern auch nur zu versuchen, mich zu überzeugen. Die Schwierigkeit, die ich dabei sehe, ist, dass dieser Mechanismus immer mehr zunimmt. Du hattest das auch verblockt neuerlich, diese Studie, die sich dem Phänomen widmete, was sie Competitive Wictimhood nannten. Also sozusagen das...
Der Übergang von Menschenwürde als Grundkonzept zu Opfertum als Grundkonzept. Genau, und möglichst Menschenwürde hat man und muss sie nicht verteidigen, aber Opfertum muss man darstellen, muss man aktiv werden und sich dafür Solidarität einwerben. Und man muss Aufmerksamkeit und Solidarität gewinnen. Das war die These von diesem Paper.
Und ich fand das sehr augeneröffnend, weil viele Phänomene relativ klar beschreibt, die wir insbesondere auch in den Medien, aber auch in Institutionen wie zum Beispiel in den USA und so weiter sehen, dass auch so kleine wahrgenommene Verstöße gegen einen angenommenen moralischen Konsens völlig überproportional aufgebläht werden und den Leuten halt Sachen unterstellt werden, die sie so nie gemeint oder nie gesagt haben, nur weil sie halt den falschen Begriff verwendet haben aus Doofheit oder weil es ihnen gerade rausgerutscht ist oder was auch immer.
Ich finde auch dieses, der ist doof, weil der das falsche Wort benutzt, finde ich völlig bescheuert. Der wichtig ist, was der sagen wollte. Wenn jemand irgendwie, also ich weiß nicht, ich sehe die Leute inzwischen alle tatsächlich ein bisschen als Opfer. Ich glaube, die haben alle dasselbe Problem, dass sie nämlich gefühlt wie im Usenet irgendwie einer unendlichen Schwemme an Leuten mit Meinungen gegenüberstehen, wo sich nur ein Teil mit ihren Meinungen bildet. Dem kann man entweder begegnen, indem man da irgendwie Sieb spielt und versucht, die alle rauszufiltern. Aber dann muss ich mich halt mit allen beschäftigen und habe pro Person irgendwie nur infinitesimal viel Zeit. Und da bleibt dann eben keine Zeit für Auseinandersetzungen. Also ich habe hier mal versucht, Argumente für die Ausgrenzung zu finden. Und das Hauptargument, was sie gefunden haben, war keine Zeit. Ja, ich habe gar keine Zeit, mich mit dem ganzen Scheiß auseinanderzusetzen. Ich muss irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass sie nicht in meiner Timeline sind, sonst explodiert mir das alles. Das ist so eine häufige Sache, aber ich glaube letztendlich habe ich dasselbe Problem wie die. Ich löse es nur anders. Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass ich jetzt aktiv rumlaufe und irgendwie Nazi-Foren lese.
Im Gegenteil, was du tust, ist du blockierst Leute, die auf den Sack gehen, einfach silent. Du schmeißt sie einfach in deine Blogliste, redest nicht weiter drüber, bist fertig. Du bereinigst deine Welt. Was die aber wiederum tun, ist, dass sie...
Nicht nur das.
Moment, aber was die wiederum tun, ist also gerade diese Empörier, ist, dass sie aktiv sagen, der muss blockiert werden.
Nicht nur das, sondern die sagen, ihr müsst endlich aufhören, irgendwie Fefes Block zu lesen. Und es sagt aber derselbe Typ fünf Jahre lang.
Der sich fünf Jahre lang darüber aufregt, dass du schreibst.
Und immer als Reaktion auf irgendwas, was ich gerade geschrieben hab. Das heißt, der kann selber nicht aufhören, das zu lesen. Und da werd ich immer so ein bisschen so, was soll denn das? Haben die nichts zu tun? Also ich block auch Leute, aber ich block die so, dass die eine Fehlermeldung kriegen. Weil das find ich affig, wenn Leute irgendwie gefiltert werden und nicht mitkriegen, dass sie gefiltert werden. Ja, weil also meine Lebenszeit erachte ich für wertvoll. Deren Lebenszeit ist auch wertvoll. Das sollen die mitkriegen. Die sollen jetzt nicht irgendwie ein Jahr lang mehr Mail schicken, die du nicht liest. Das find ich auch affig. Also dann sag ich denen lieber, hör mal zu, jetzt hast du irgendwie hier die Grenze überschritten, geh weg. Ja, und wer das nicht mitkriegt und weiter mailt, der kommt ins Kill-File und kriegt dann halt auf SMTP-Ebenen Bounds, einfach die Mail-Bounds dann halt.
Aber du gehst jetzt nicht hin und irgendwie publizierst dein Kill-File?
Ich mache nicht irgendwie, ich blogge nicht, den Typ habe ich jetzt gebloggt, weil er doof ist.
Diese 100 Leute sind irgendwie...
Und das verstehe ich auch nicht. Was soll denn das?
Ja, völlig erbutscht.
Da kann irgendwie nichts Gutes draus kommen, wenn man öffentlich Leute so ankackt.
Der vor allen Dingen...
Der einzige, der dabei schlecht aussieht, ist der, der es tut. Der sieht einfach aus wie jemand, der das nötig hat, irgendwie sich selbst auf, auf wie das andere noch schlimmer sind, aufzuwerten.
Genau, deshalb nämlich genau dieses Ich bin Opfer deiner Meinungsäußerung. Das ist halt genau dieses Spiel, was dabei rumkommt.
Ich glaube, dass man das auf einen älteren Mechanismus zurückführen kann, dass man sagen kann, wenn ich öffentlich sage, der ist doof, dann sage ich damit, ich habe mich damit beschäftigt. Ich habe die Zeit gehabt und ich habe mir das angeguckt und ich bin zu diesem Ergebnis gekommen. Das heißt, ich habe mehr Zeit investiert als du. Das ist eine Aufwertung von mir selbst. Ich habe an der Stelle zumindest mehr Erfahrungen als du. Und ich glaube, das ist der Hintergrund, dass man sich selbst aufwertet, indem man andere abwertet. Aber nicht als Selbstzweck, sondern weil man sagt, man könnte genauso gut positiv das machen. Aber das ist ja geächtet bei uns. Du bist ja ein Fanboy. Das heißt, da bleibt eigentlich nur andere Leute. Ich spreche mich da auch nicht völlig frei von. Also ich stalk auch Apple zum Beispiel seit vielen Jahren und ärgere mich jedes Mal über die Aufmerksamkeit, die die kriegen. Aber ich laufe den jetzt nicht hinterher, sondern ist genauso. Ich meine, Realitätsfeld wird irgendwie, kriegt eine Invasion aus Apple Fanboys, von denen ich nun leider auch umgeben bin, du wirst hust.
Ich finde es ja ein sehr schönes Beispiel. Also es ist halt so ein kollektives Reality-Distortion-Field, was in deiner Wahrnehmung viel krasser ist, als es eigentlich ist.
Vielleicht ist auch deine Wahrnehmung zu sanft.
Nein. Okay, das ist halt so ein Ding, die meisten Leute, die du als Apple-Fanboys betrachtest in deiner Umgebung.
Sind eigentlich auch Opfer.
Nee. Weißt du, die sind halt nicht wirklich Fanboys. Deshalb die benutzen halt nur das aus ihrer Sicht kleinere Übel. Und echtes Fanboy-Tum sieht halt echt anders aus, eigentlich so. Na ja.
Warte mal, wir sind hier noch nicht durch mit den drei Argumenten für die Ausgrenzung. Das erste war keine Zeit. Das zweite war, die Inhalte von dem sind kategorisch so widerlich, dass die aus dem Diskurs verbannt werden sollten. Also aus inhaltlichen Gründen muss das weg. Und das dritte ist so ein bisschen verwandt mit keine Zeit. Das ist so ein Effizienzargument, ja, dass ich sage, diese Debatte wird nicht nach vorne gehen, solange wir so viele Leute reinlassen.
Ich möchte gerne gerade mich auf ein anderes Niveau bewegen.
Ich will hier Fortschritt haben und das wird nicht stattfinden, solange meine Zeit mit Leuten wie das hier mit Argumenten wie diesem hier gebunden werden. Und teilweise ist ja alles davon verständlich. Das ist ja nicht irgendwie moralisch schlecht oder böse. Und ich glaube, die Ausgrenzung ist eine Sache, die wir alle schon immer gemacht haben. Kennt man ja vom Schulhof sogar, dass man irgendwie sagt, der gehört jetzt aber nicht zu unserer Clique. Und es ist immer ein sozialer Aufwertungsversuch, dass man sich darüber definiert, wer alles nicht dazu gehört. Den lassen wir aber nicht rein. Unsere Standards sind so hoch, dass der nicht rein darf.
Naja, da muss ich aber nochmal eine Lanze tatsächlich für die Ausgrenzung an einigen Stellen brechen. Also teilweise ein Kontergerührung meines Einwesens.
Je höher der, den ich ausgrenze, im sozialen Rang steht, desto höher ist die Aufwertung, die ich durch seine Ausgrenzung erfahre. Wenn ich irgendwie einen obdachlosen ausgrenze, habe ich viel weniger Prestige gewonnen, als wenn ich die Bildzeitung ausgrenze.
Oder Sarrazin oder wer noch mehr hat.
Ja, und deswegen sieht man so häufig Leute, die sich einfach irgendwelche Gegner suchen, die überhaupt keinen Berührungspunkt haben, außer dass sie da sind und Aufmerksamkeit gewinnen im Internet oder überhaupt. Und an denen reibt man sich dann, weil man irgendwie am meisten Prestige durch deren Abkanzlung gewinnen kann gegenüber irgendwelchen Opfern. Dann nimmt man lieber jemanden, der groß ist, oder?
Gut, ich will trotzdem noch mal ausgehen von meiner These, dass das Internet einfach zu groß ist, wenn man so vier Ausgrenzungen bricht. Ich habe das ja schon mal in so einem Blogpost geschrieben. Ich denke, dass das Problem, was wir haben, ist, dass wir keine deklarierten, guten Strukturen für Closed User Groups haben. Sondern dass dieser Mischmasch, dieses Nicht-Deklarieren von hier handelt es sich um eine interne Kommunikation, also intern im Sinne von Kommunikation mit einem vorausgesetzten Grundniveau oder einem vorausgesetzten ähnlichen Meinungsfeld zu diesem Thema. Versus es handelt es sich um eine öffentliche Gruppe, wo man auch Leute einfangen will, wo man die auch der Mission dient, wenn man mal halt den... Also die Kirche hat das ja relativ gut. Also die hat dann eine gute Trennung. Die hat halt ihre Theologie. Und da klopfen sich dann halt irgendwie um die schwierigen theologischen Fragen. Und sie hat die Mission. Und da ist halt vollkommen klar, die Mission redet halt mit jedem. Wenn sie missionieren gehen, reden sie halt mit jedem. Und keine Frage ist ihnen zu dumm. Also es ist halt extrem... Also bis du einen Missionar weggeschickt bekommst mit dummen Fragen, musst du halt schon echt was tun, wenn er halbwegs gut ist. Und wie ein Theologe, wenn du eine theologische Debatte führst, wird halt vorausgesetzt, dass du bestimmte Dinge kannst, weißt, dass du...
Auch so siehst.
Naja, nicht mal zwingt, aber dass du zumindest...
Die Orthodoxie nahe war. Wenn du hängst und sagst, ja, aber vielleicht die Ufer Maria, vielleicht war das ja ganz anders.
Dann bist du ein Ketzer. Ketzer ist schwierig. Ketzer sind sozusagen Leute, die in theologischen Debatten eine völlig abseitige Meinung vertreten, obwohl sie über das gesamte Wissen verfügen. Dann bist du Ketzer. Der interessante Punkt daran ist, dass diese diese Struktur natürlich dazu führt, dass Debatten sehr langwierig sind, dass sie nicht besonders offen sind, dass es halt kaum frische Luft da drin gibt. Sondern du musst halt erst mal, bis du da hinkommst, dass du mit den Leuten auf dem Level debattieren kannst, musst du halt irgendwie erst mal extrem viel Zeit zu bringen und investieren. Und deswegen ist es ja eigentlich ganz gut, dass wir, also auf diesem Level relativ gut, dass wir diesen Effekt halt in Netzdebatten oder auch in gesellschaftlichen Debatten nicht haben. Aber uns fehlt, glaube ich, tatsächlich das Äquivalent zur theologischen Debatte. Also tatsächlich zu Strukturen, zu Möglichkeiten, Debatten voranzubringen, ohne uns ständig irgendwie in Echo-Kammern zu begeben. Also ohne sozusagen diesen Effekt von selbstverstärkung dauernd zu haben, ohne dass wir uns durch Ausgrenzung oder aktive nach außen kommunizierte Ausgrenzung von anderen abtrennen müssen, dass wir diese selbstverstärkung brauchen und so. Die sind ja eigentlich alle nicht notwendig. Das ist ja so, wenn man sich halt irgendwie zum Thema unterhalten will, was halt einen relativ klaren Faktenbaum hat und eine Lösung benötigt, dann kann man ja auch einfach sagen, okay, wir ziehen uns hier mal hin zurück in diese Struktur, in diese Gruppe. Bloß wir haben das nicht. Wir haben diese Strukturen dafür nicht.
Gibt es denn überhaupt Sachen, wo man tatsächlich eine Closed-User-Gruppe hat? Also ist mir noch nicht begegnet, wo es nicht vorkommen kann, dass da noch jemand dazu stößt.
Na ja, Meldinglisten.
Du willst doch, dass da Leute sich auch subscriben können.
Ich bin auf diversen Meldinglisten, wo Subscription highly regulated ist.
Natürlich regulated, aber nicht existent.
Nee, im Sinne von du wirst eingeladen, wenn du fünf Bürgern hast, so dann...
Na ja, aber es kann trotzdem vorkommen.
Ja, aber es ist nicht völlig closed jedenfalls. Die Gruppe erweitert sich aber aussichst selbst. Du kommst nicht dazu, sondern du wirst eingeladen.
Also es gibt noch einen Seiten Aspekt, den ich noch beleuchten möchte, die Frage, nämlich wie du die Unterscheidung triffst, ob jetzt ein Posting auf Topic ist oder nicht. Das ist nämlich auch immer wieder...
Im Newsnet war das ja eigentlich das hauptwesentliche Debattenthema.
Eigentlich nicht, es kamen immer sehr viele... Also es ist meistens sehr offensichtlich, wenn jemand in einer M-Gruppe über Mut postet, dann ist klar, der ist hier falsch. Oder in einer V.I.-Gruppe über Emacs, dann weiß man, der ist hier falsch.
Fieser Heretiker, ja.
Aber da stellt sich eben auch die Frage, kann man das irgendwie automatisieren? Das ist immer so eine Frage. Kann man das so machen, dass eine Maschine das sogar beantworten kann, ob das jetzt hier ein Topic ist oder nicht, um es gerecht zu machen, ja, weil du willst ja Willkür ausschließen. Die Frage ist, ob du so eine Closed-User-Gruppe nicht über die Personen machen kannst, sondern über den Inhalt, ja, dass man sagt, hier darf zwar jeder rein, aber wenn er irgendwie Sachen schreibt, die scheiße sind, dann tauchen die nicht auf.
Also eigentlich sollte es mittlerweile gehen.
Also wenn ich nämlich anfange und ich baue das auf Vertrauen auf, das skaliert erstens nicht und zum zweiten kann es sein, dass sich die Person ändert einfach. Oder hat mich beschissen. Das kann auch sein.
Beschissen oder was sie falsch eingeschätzt.
Das ist nämlich alles gar nicht so einfach, wie man sowas vernünftig machen würde. Und im Normalfall würde ich sogar inzwischen argumentieren, dass man durch die Eingrenzung mehr verliert, als man gewinnt. Also wenn es eine Deadline gibt und es geht, sagen wir mal, um die Organisierungsmeldingliste für irgendeine Veranstaltung. Das ist was anderes.
Okay, das war das andere, aber das ist ein Projekt. Aber die, also aber nehmen wir mal zum Beispiel jetzt gerade so den Fall von Reddit, ne? Da ist es halt so, dass die, da haben die halt so viel gepostet, dass der Rest einfach nicht mehr aufgedauert ist. Dass die Moderatoren dann halt hätten einen Großteil der Postings löschen müssen. Und viel davon war jetzt, also nicht viel, aber einiges davon war jetzt auch nicht so offensichtlicher Nazi-Kram, sondern halt so Zweifel-Sehen-Meldungen, teilweise Fake-Meldungen. So halt so die typischen Vergewaltigungsfälle in Bayern. Warum sagt die Polizei nicht, dass irgendwie zwei Migranten die tatverdächtigen sind? So diese Art von Postings, die es von den sehr viele gibt, um halt einfach so so eine Grundstimmung zu sehen sind. Die sind halt einfach nicht in der Ehe gekommen. Die sind halt nicht, also ihre ganzen Systeme haben halt versagt, um den Charakter dieser Gruppe zu erhalten.
Das liegt auch daran, dass die normalen Verfahren entweder so gebaut sind, dass sie skalieren, aber dann sind sie nicht gerecht, oder sind so gebaut, dass sie gerecht sind, aber dann skalieren sie nicht. Das ist ja auch ein Problem, was wir generell in der Gesellschaft haben. Und deswegen haben wir auch diese mehrphasige höhere Instanzen von Gerichten, die noch mal untere Instanzen kassieren können. So ein Problem gibt es ja überall. Und wenn du so eine Gruppe aufbaust unter der Prämisse, dass es schon irgendwie grob Konsens gibt, dann brauchst du auch nichts, was irgendwie skaliert. Ja, weil dann gibt es nur, dann ist das dann ein Sonderfall. Und es gibt noch einen Aspekt, der da reinspielt, nämlich dieses verschiedene Verständnis von Free Speech. Ja, dass man einfach redet als amerikanische Site oder vertritt ja auch amerikanische Ideen und Konzepte. Und zum Beispiel die Idee, dass man ein News-Posting löscht, weil es Fake-News ist. Das ist zum Beispiel nicht völlig unkontrovers. Da könnte man auch sagen, das behalten wir bei und schreiben es irgendwie dahinter. Achtung, Fake. Oder das reicht, wenn es in den Kommentaren steht. Und ansonsten ist es nämlich Zensur. Und Zensur wollen wir hier nicht. Also da gibt es sowieso ein Grundproblem, was wir eigentlich noch mal in Ruhe ansprechen wollten hier. Die verschiedenen Aspekte zur freien Meinungsausschauung. Denn das ist ja auch hinter diesem Facebook-Problem gerade. Ja, Facebook ist ja eine große Firma, die von sich aus einfach aus bürokratischen Gründen a. klare Regeln braucht, was gelöscht wird, und b. so wenig wie möglich löschen will, weil das ihre User-Basis ist. Und damit verdienen sie Geld. Je mehr Inhalte, desto besser.
Und je kontroverse die Inhalte, desto mehr Klicks.
Genau. Und gerade, dass jetzt fast jedes zweite News-Meldung gerade über Facebook und die Lösch-Diskussion ist, treibt den wahrscheinlich richtig den Traffic hoch.
Na gut, ich meine aber die Frage der Tradition, der freien Meinungsäußerung und welche...
Wie geht man damit um, dass andere Leute Sachen sagen, die man widerlich findet? Das ist ja die Kernfrage.
Na ja, und wir haben ja da diesen grundsätzlich verschiedenen Ansatz zwischen Europa und den USA. Also das ist ja nur Konzentraleuropa und den USA, der halt kulturell gewachsen ist, der halt auch aus dem Anspruch der Gesellschaft resultiert, zu sagen, wir wollen bestimmte Dinge nicht. Also spezifisch nach dem Krieg, dass Nazi-Propaganda verboten ist, dass bestimmte Propaganda für bestimmte Formen von Diskriminierung verboten sind. Und die Möglichkeiten, das durchzusetzen, sind halt mit dem Internet quasi dramatisch gesunken. Weil du immer eine Methode findest, deine Meinung, die in Deutschland technisch gesehen illegal wäre, irgendwo zu publizieren. Und Facebook ist halt...
Das war ein relativ frühes Problem. Wie hieß das? Stormfront oder so? Die es da gab von irgendeinem Exildeutschen in Canada oder so.
Ja, da gibt es viele solche Seiten.
Ja, aber die ist so relativ notorisch gewesen damals, weil die Staatsanwaltschaft sich wirklich bemüht hat, die wegzukriegen. Und der Kampf hat sich jahrelang hingezogen und war am Ende nicht erfolgreich. Aber das Konzept Hate Speech gibt es auch einfach gar nicht in den USA. Das ist ein Lehnbegriff aus Europa.
Das gibt es schon, also insbesondere auf zu weit tätigen Rassismus. Es fällt da richtig unter Hate Speech.
Ja, aber das ist nichts, das muss jetzt weg, weil Hate Speech...
Doch, gibt es. Ach, echt? Ja, gibt es. Aber das ist eben tatsächlich der Aufruf zur Gewalt.
Ja gut, also wir sehen es ja deutlich enger hier.
Ja, bei uns ist es halt völlig viel enger und es ist auch ein Kernding, dass die Dinge, die du hier sagen kannst im gesellschaftlichen Diskurs oder online oder wo auch immer oder drucken kannst, sind halt weniger. Also um es mal ganz neutral zu formulieren. Man kann durchaus sagen, dass es zum Teil gut ist. Also dass es halt irgendwie dazu führt, dass der, dass möglicherweise das Spektrum der publizierten Meinung schmaler ist. Aber...
Ja, ist das denn gut oder ist das schlecht?
Aber es ist möglicherweise eben doch tatsächlich so, dass der, dass die Propaganda oder die Mission für solche Dinge eingeschränkt ist, eben dadurch, dass sie eben nicht alles sagen können, sondern viele Sachen andeuten müssen oder umschreiben müssen oder was auch immer, dass sie dadurch weniger effizient sind, zumindest die Theorie. Und die Frage ist, stimmt das noch? Oder?
Ich glaube, das hat nie gestimmt. Weißt du, ich bin immer total schockiert, wenn mir irgendwelche Leute erzählen, dieses Autokennzeichen war irgendwie Nazi, wegen, weil da was irgendwie 8, 4 oder irgendeine Zahlenkombination auftaucht. Und wenn man, dann kommen so Numerologiegeschichten, die man sieht, 19 von irgendwelchen.
Die sind aber tatsächlich üblich bei denen.
Ja, natürlich. Aber weißt du, auf dem Niveau müssen wir jetzt verhandeln, was, was irgendwie, wenn du mir erklären musst, warum das ein Problem ist, auf dem Niveau müssen wir verhandeln, dann muss es trotzdem verfolgt oder verboten werden. So, ja, ich will noch mal sagen, die Amerikaner haben zwar freie Meinungsaussorgung, aber sowas wie üble Nachrede oder Aufruf zu Straftaten oder Geschäftsschädigungen oder Urheberrecht haben die selbstverständlich auch. Man kann nicht einfach irgendwie sagen, ich mach jetzt hier ein Büro der New York Times und blende da meine Werbung ein und das ist jetzt freie Meinungsaussorgung. Also es ist bei weitem nicht so, dass man in Amerika alles sagen darf. Nur in politischen Fragen sehen die das halt anders und sagen, okay wir haben hier diese ganzen Waffen nahen und irgendwie, die haben ja auch Nazi-Probleme, das ist nur anders strukturiert als bei uns. Die können halt irgendwie sagen, was sie wollen, solange es nicht einschlägig irgendwas anderes betrifft, wofür wir Paragrafen haben. Aber im Wesentlichen muss die Gesellschaft das halt aushalten und das führt meines Erachtens zu einem deutlich weniger hysterischen Umgang mit dem Problem.
Aber es führt auch dazu, Gegenargument, dass es in Amiland eben diese riesige Riesenschäden gibt, dass da eben tatsächlich so einen rassistischen White-Power-Kultur-Kreis gibt, der halt auch irgendwie große Überschneidung mit den ganzen Waffennahen hat und der auch so groß ist, eben weil er halt ungehindert kommunizieren kann. So die These. Und dass das bei uns halt eben tatsächlich auch erst so groß geworden ist, nicht nur durch die sozialen Umstände, sondern eben auch dadurch, dass sie halt jetzt ungehindert kommunizieren können.
Was sind das? Sind immer Sachen, wo ich gerne Belege für sehen würde. Hätte ich gern Zahlen, damit ich das anfassen kann. Wie viel Prozent Nazis in der Bevölkerung gibt es in den USA? Und wie viel hier? Das hätte ich gern mal gewusst. Ich weiß, dass sich das wie ein Riesenproblem anfühlt. Und dass man in den Wahlen jetzt sieht, die NPD zielt in diesen Kreistag und in diesen Landtag ein. Aber wenn ich mir angucke, wie beschissen die Wahlbeteiligung bei uns ist, dann bleibt am Ende von den großen Prozentzahlen nicht mehr viel übrig. Und ich finde, wir müssen weg davon kommen, diese Diskussionen so hysterisch emotional aufgeladen zu führen. Und wir müssen einfach versuchen, dass wir mal die Fakten auf dem Tisch legen und sagen, was ist denn eigentlich unser konkretes Problem? Was wollen wir nicht? Ja, und dann können wir uns auch überlegen, was müssen wir tun, um das zu erreichen? Und ich finde so Gedankenverbote generell gefährlich. Nicht weil ich irgendwie Bock hab, mich mit Nazi irgendwie Propaganda auseinanderzusetzen, sondern weil ich mir immer denke, am Ende kann so eine Regelung auch mal umgedreht werden, wenn hier irgendwie sich der Wind im Land dreht. Ja, und irgendwann wir hier eine noch faschistische Regierung kriegen, als wäre jetzt schon irgendwie die Sicherheits- und Innenminister drehen ja jetzt schon seit Jahren frei. Und wenn Gedankenverbote und dieses Wort darf nicht gesagt werden und wenn jemand sich bedroht fühlt, dann ist das schon ein Angriff, wenn diese Art von Denke sich durchsetzt, dann wird das irgendwann gegen mich angewendet werden. Ja, und dann mache ich mir echt Sorgen. Denn das ist für mich eines der faszinierendsten Gebiete in der Geschichte, ist einfach wie es in Deutschland zu den Nazis kam. Das war ja ein schleichtender Übergang. Und ich frage mich auf der Skala, in welchem Jahr sind wir eigentlich heute? Also unter der Annahme, dass wir auch auf so was zugehen, sind wir da nicht vielleicht schon auf der Skala. Ja, und wenn ja, welches Jahr wäre das? Und ich denke, da muss man immer seine Umgebung danach Ausschau halten, damit man das nicht erst merkt, wenn es zu spät ist und man das nicht mehr umdrehen kann. Und dann im Zweifelsfall lieber für die Freiheit und argumentativ gegen die Nazis. Und wenn es überhaupt nicht klappt, dann strafrechtlich gegen die Nazis. Und wenn strafrechtlich überhaupt nicht klappt, dann kann man irgendwie überlegen, ob man da Militia macht oder halt die Intoleranz nicht duldet. Das kann man ja irgendwie debattieren. Aber ich finde, dann hat unser Rechtstem versagt. Wenn wir uns Gedanken machen müssen, was wir tun, wenn die Strafverfolgung nicht funktioniert. Diese Diskussion will ich ehrlich gesagt nicht führen, ob ich dann irgendwie eine Waffe nehmen muss, um meine Werte zu verteidigen. Sondern ich finde, das darf man es wohl nicht kommen lassen. Und dazu gehört eben auch, dass ich jetzt dieser Pharaon gegenüber trete und sage, das ist jetzt alles verboten. Das finde ich gefährlich, nicht einfach verbieten. Du kannst nicht einfach sagen, das Problem geht nicht weg, wenn ich es ignoriere. Wir haben die Nazis jahrelang ignoriert und schauen, wo wir jetzt sind.
Naja, der Punkt ist, es ist nicht so, dass wir die Nazis ignoriert haben, sondern der Staat hat die Nazis. Das finde ich schon eine ganz wichtige Unterhaltung.
Ich bin ja ich.
Ach du bist der Staat.
Die agieren in meinem Namen. Das ist meine Verantwortung, wenn der Staat das noch macht.
Tatsächlich ist es ja so, dass zivilgesellschaftlicher, gerade die Beobachtung und der aktive Kampf gegen die Nazi-Strukturen insbesondere in der Provinz schon seit vielen Jahren echt intensiv läuft.
Ja und ich finde das wirklich furchtbar, dass das irgendwelche Milizen machen müssen von Freiwilligen und dass unser Staat die finanziert, anstatt die zu bekämpfen. Das finde ich wirklich entsetzlich.
Dass der Staat da halt einfach nicht in der Lage ist, halt aktiv gegen vorzugehen, sondern im Gegenteil. Haltteile des Sicherheitsapparats, mit denen halt irgendwie sympathisieren und die unterstützen, ist eben auch ein Teil des Problems.
Die CDU möchte ihre Wählerstimmen sichern.
Also ich meine mal ganz ehrlich, das war so einer der Tweets irgendwie in den letzten zwei oder drei Wochen, die ich auch dachte, so recht hatte. Nämlich was wäre denn, wenn diese ganzen Angriffe, die da gerade passieren von den Nazis auf die Flüchtlingsnamen, die ganzen Brandanschläge, die ganzen Überfälle, wenn das halt Muslims wären. Also wenn das halt sozusagen die Angriffe von denen aus gingen, dann hätten wir hier einen Terrorgeschrei bis zum Mond. Ja, so sieht es aus. Also dann wäre hier Ausnahmezustand.
Und jetzt gehen wir noch einen Schritt weiter und sagen, sagen wir mal, das sind Moslems, die Synagogen angreifen.
Ja, zum Beispiel sowas, denn wir...
Ja, also wir müssen einfach zu einem Gedankenmodell und Rechtsmodell kommen, indem wir davon abstrahieren, wer jetzt gegen wen was tut, sondern die eigentliche Straftat ist das Relevante.
Korrekt. Das ist halt genau der Punkt, den wir halt da brauchen.
Und deswegen finde ich Sachen wie, die Nazis dürfen das und das nicht. Hier sind Scheiße. Keiner darf das. Entweder keiner oder alle.
Ja. Und das ist halt so ein Punkt, der nicht mehr, also ich vermute eben auch nicht mehr so unarbeitet zurückzudrehen ist. Da ist halt einfach die Schwierigkeit, einen unideologischen Rechtsstaat zu haben, also einen, der halt irgendwie nicht auf dem rechten Auge blind ist und der halt auch in der Lage ist, gegen religiös motivierte Gewalt halt irgendwie sinnvoll vorzugehen, das wieder herzustellen, wird halt echt schwierig. Weil strukturell ist halt gerade der Verfassungsschutz und irgendwie Teile halt der Polizei, die halt irgendwie solche Dinge betrachten, sind halt irgendwie, naja, die sind halt irgendwie Rechte, also die würden halt wahrscheinlich ohne mit der Wimper zu zucken AfD wählen, so wenn du mit denen redest, so. Und deren Fokus sind halt...
Und weißt du was, solange das nicht verboten ist, die Partei find ich das okay.
Ja, bloß...
Das muss unser Land aushalten.
Bloß dann brauch ich halt eben die Strukturen in den Behörden, die dafür sorgen, dass da keiner aus ideologischen Gründen was nicht verfolgt. Genau, klar. Und das sollte hier gehen. Und das sollte ein echtes Problem sein.
Also ich könnte mich schon aufregen, wenn Leute andere Leute beschimpfen, weil sie AfD wählen. Ja, also wir haben hier die Demokratieleute, wenn die Mehrheit sich dafür findet, dass wir hier irgendwie Nazi-Gedanken gut haben, dann ist das nicht ein Problem der AfD, dann ist das ein Problem unserer Gesellschaft. Dieses Finger zeigen immer als, als wenn dadurch ich von den Problemen befreit wäre, wenn ich da nur hinten hinzeige und sage, die sind schuld. Das ist unser aller Problem. Das geht nicht weg, wenn du in deiner Filterblase auf irgendwie zensieren klickst. So ein Scheiß, ey. Und am Ende bleiben dann wieder nur so, weißt du, drei, vier Leute übrig, die überhaupt Zeit und Muße haben, sich mit dem Problem zu beschäftigen, weil der Reste weggefiltert hat. Wir haben ja hier diverse Interessen, die auch gegeneinander arbeiten und gegen uns, die einfach gar kein Interesse daran haben. Wie gesagt, ich habe ja schon gesagt, ich befürchte so ein bisschen, dass das gerade aktiv gegen die Wand gefahren wird, damit wir diese Flüchtlingsfrage ein für alle mal klären. Ich glaube auch übrigens, dass der Atomausstieg so was war. Ja, zumindest partiell, dass sie behauptet haben, dass das alles richtig platzt.
Das war zumindest der Versuch.
Und plötzlich und überraschend ist es nicht geplatzt und jetzt haben sie halt ein Problem und können es nicht wieder zurückdrehen.
Ja, gut, ich meine, in der Frage der Integration der Flüchtlinge halte ich das auch für wahrscheinlich, weil am Ende, was wir jetzt vermutlich erst mal kriegen werden, dass das erst mal Schengen endet. So wie die Lage sich gerade darstellt, wenn man irgendwie dieses Protokoll von der Innenministerkonferenz liest.
Wobei das echt unpopulär ist. Also da müsste, glaube ich, noch ein Anschlag passieren, damit es geht. Meinst du nicht?
Da bin ich nicht so sicher. Also das Schengen abschaffen wäre halt echt unpopulär. Das hatten wir ja mit Rob letztes Mal in der Diskussion. Der sagte, naja, dann werden sie halt irgendwas einführen, dass es sich für dich anfühlt wie Schengen. Das ist halt irgendwie erster Grund, dass das moderne Überwachungsstaat nicht zu belästigen und nicht belästigt werden muss.
Und man zur Priorität irgendwie durchwinken beim Flughafen-Style?
Long-Ranger-FID-Tags an die Pässe für Europäer und irgendwie alle anderen.
Werden halt zufällig rausgesogen.
Werden halt irgendwie rausgesogen. Also sowas vermute ich mal, darauf wird es halt hinauslaufen. Zumindest mittelfristig, aber...
Technologie.
Ich bin halt... Also ich glaube halt schon, dass wir wahrscheinlich noch diesen Winter erleben werden, dass die Schengen ausmachen für eine Weile. Und das dann halt erst mal als temporärent vorübergehend deklarieren.
Weißt du, der Punkt, wo ich gesagt hab, das ist doch hier strukturelles Versagen, ist, als diese Meldungen hochkamen, dass sie da den Leuten keine Pässe gegeben haben. Den Flüchtlingen. Das war so eine dieser Meldungen, dass organisatorisch bei den Flüchtlingen was verkackt wird.
Wie meinst du?
Die haben einfach reingewunken und die haben jetzt keine Papiere. Na gut und das gibt doch, das gibt das Platz doch irgendwo. Irgendwann platzt das doch. Du kannst dann einfach hier. Und jetzt, jetzt brauchen die irgendeine Leistung vom Staat und haben keine Papiere. Das kann noch nur komplett in die Hose gehen. Und wenn so was überhaupt stattfinden kann, dann denke ich mir doch, das ist doch Absicht.
Also wenn man sich überlegt, dass bisher halt die deutsche Einwanderungspolitik wurde ja nicht von der Politik gemacht, weil wir haben ja kein richtiges Einwanderungsgesetz. Sondern halt vom Ausländeramt. De facto, was die Demokraten da auf der Basis von Dienstanweisungen und eigenen Messen getan haben, war ja die deutsche Einwanderungspolitik. Und was die da gerade veranstalten, halt mit irgendwie, was war jetzt die Zahl?
Heute früh war es irgendwie 120.000 im Wochenende allein.
Ja, und sie, wie war es, 100? Also irgendwie so die Zahl war so ungefähr jeder Beamte in diesem, diesem Amt. Irgendwie ein Flüchtling am Tag oder so was. Ja, also irgendwie so völlig oder 1,2 oder 1,8 oder so. Also völlig utopisch niedrige Zahl. So, wo du denkst, für die Nachbereitung haben wir gar nicht die Infrastruktur.
Und die bürokratische Infrastruktur, die andere natürlich schon.
Ja, also keine Ahnung, was der BND macht. Wahrscheinlich irgendwie da über seine Leute jetzt irgendwie ins Ausländeramt schicken, damit die halt irgendwie die...
Ich sehe schon die Bundeswehr mit einem Einsatz an den Schreibmaschinen.
Ja, gut, das wäre immerhin ja mal eine Option, ja. Aber ich glaube halt, dass diese These, dass da Leute gibt, die es halt absichtlich verkacken, dass wir die im Auge behalten müssen. Also dass es halt schon durchaus Leute gibt in der Struktur, die wissen, was sie verkacken müssen und was sie falsch organisieren müssen, damit dieses Projekt irgendwie gegen jemand fährt. Und das ist halt etwas, wo die Regierung natürlich irgendwie schon sich fragen lassen muss, wie es dann so um ihre Souveränität ging bei dem Beamtenapparat auslitt. Naja.
So, wir sind zeitlich eigentlich so gut wie durch. Wir haben jetzt hier noch zwei, drei Punkte. In sich geschlossene Denkgerüste beruhen auf unausgesprochenen Annahmen. Und bei den beiden reden dann beidereinander vorbei. Da hatte ich leider nur ein relativ doofes Beispiel, finde ich.
Nämlich?
Na, diese Feminismusgeschichte bei der Oxford Union. Wo ich den Eindruck hatte, dass einfach die ganzen doofen Fragen, also jetzt im FAQ-Sinne, nicht aus dem Weg geräumt wurden, sondern dass beide Seiten unausgesprochene Annahmen hatten. Die eine Seite meinte, das spreche ich jetzt nicht an, weil das ist die Bringschuld der anderen Seite. Und die andere Seite spricht es nicht an, weil sie das für völlig unkontrovers hält. Und dann haben wir zwei Leute, die eine Argumentationskette aufbauen, die in sich geschlossen ist, aber die im anderen Koordinatensystem liegt. Und die sind völlig inkompatibel und beide sind an sich richtig. Aber ich als Betrachter brauche irgendwie einen Tag, um zu verstehen, warum das trotzdem nicht beides funktioniert. Irgendeiner hat ja Recht und einer hat Unrecht. Oder wie man sich da oder einem kann ich mich anschließen und dem anderen nicht. Aber das ist eben allein durch Betrachten der Beiträge nicht zu sehen. Und ich glaube, die Schuld liegt daran, dass wir heute einfach diese Spin-Doktor-Perfektionismus-Kultur haben. Dass die Leute sich nicht trauen, ihre Gedankengänge außerhalb der Filterblase zu testen oder vorzubringen.
Ich meine, es ist vollkommen klar, warum, ne?
Bis sie fertig sind, ja.
Weil natürlich in dem Anblick, wo dir halt irgendwie ein Gedanke, die du mal ins Unreine gesprochen hast, oder ein Wort, was du...
Fügt mir gleich um die Ohren, oder?...
mit dir sofort um die Ohren gehauen, du hast keine Möglichkeit, irgendwie einen Gedanken zu entwickeln, weil du eigentlich immer, wenn dadurch das alles dokumentiert ist, dass irgendwie alles dir vorgehalten werden kann, musst du immer perfekt sein. Und das ist halt so ein Ding, wo ich mich auch gegenwehre, wo ich sage, okay, weißt du, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie erstmal einen Gedanken und eine reine Formulierung hinterher feststelle, dass er falsch ist und du nimmst diesen Satz und ignorierst, was ich danach gesagt habe, was ja in vielen von diesen angeblichen Sexismus-Skandalen der letzten Monate halt ja häufig der Fall war.
Ja, auch der Grundstein der Debatte sozusagen, ist man dem anderen gesagt, okay, mit dem müssen wir nicht reden, seine Argumente müssen wir nicht hören, weil der hat diesen einen falschen Satz. Der hat 1993 in diesem Usenet-Forum.
Genau.
Ja, ich glaube, das hat auch seinen Start in den Politikdebatten gehabt, wo besonders in den USA dieses Flip-Flop-Argument gibt, dass man gesagt hat, der hat aber vor 15 Jahren diesen Satz gesagt, im Country Club in Ohio auf dem Klo, auf dem Männerklo, hat er irgendwie als zufällig dieser Journalist dabei, war das gesagt. Und die Idee, dass man auf Wachsen und seine Position ändern kann, was ich ja das zentrale Feature von Diskursen finde, das geht verloren.
Das Recht, seine Meinung zu ändern. Also nicht nur Recht, es ist Pflicht.
Es ist meine Pflicht, meine Meinung änderbar zu halten. Natürlich, ich muss bei allem, was ich sage, davon ausgehen, dass ich gerade scheiße rede. Aber um das rauszufinden, muss ich es äußern dürfen, ohne dass jemand sofort sagt, der ist aber doof. Vor allem, und das ist die Sache, die mich bei Twitter am meisten nervt, ist, dass dieser Aspekt, warum ist denn es jetzt doof, überhaupt nicht einmal ausgeführt wird, sondern da kommt dann nur noch, boah, ist der doof.
Die Moralkeule direkt so.
Das ist ja alles falsch. Guck mal, was der schon wieder für Scheiße schreibt und dann aber keinerlei Ausführungen, welcher Aspekt davon jetzt schlecht ist oder warum er schlecht ist.
Und hypokritisch bis zum Gegend, bis zum Abwinken.
Kann ich ja mitleben, ja. Aber ein Argument, jemand anderem zu sagen, das war alles falsch und dann aber nicht zu sagen, was jetzt das Konkrete, der konkrete Punkt ist, wo man nicht übereinstimmt, das kann ich überhaupt nicht mit umgehen.
Oder sich weigern zu erklären.
Boah, sind die Leute doof, weil mir hilft das nicht. Drittlesern hilft das nicht. Und dem hilft es auch nicht, der da rumgepoltert hat, weil der stellt sich da als jemand, der…
Ja, dann blößt sich als ein Tottel.
Ja, aber…
Ich hab das Problem ja gelegt.
Für mich ist das einfach zeitverschwendung, so was zu sehen, weil mir das nicht weiterhilft. Und ich möchte gern, dass die Leute mir zeigen, wenn ich irgendwo falsch liege.
Also mein Kennzeichen dafür, wie verkorkst eine Debatte ist, ist, wenn ich nicht dazukommen kann und eine Verständnisfrage stellen kann.
Ja, genau.
Das ist halt so… Und ich hab das halt auf Twitter häufiger, weil ich bin ja nun vielfältig interessiert, aber ich hab einfach nicht von allen eine Ahnung. Und wenn ich halt zu einer Debatte dazukomme und frage, warum ist denn das so? Also, was ist denn der Grund, warum ich das jetzt nicht sagen darf, warum das ein falsches Wort ist, hier gerade dieses Social Justice Warrior?
Und da brauchen wir eine FAQ. So, genau. Für so eine Scheiße brauchen wir die FAQ, damit du sowas nicht fragen musst, sondern nachgucken kannst.
Ja, genau. Und was ich da gerne hätte, da wäre halt irgendwie ein, hier liest da, so ist es halt, so sehen wir die Lage.
Wobei, das machen die ja, aber sie verweisen da nicht auf die Antwort, sondern auf den Festmeter Literatur.
Genau, auf den Festmeter.
Und das ist ja völlig sinnlos, reine geistige Masturbationsübung.
Na ja, und das führt halt dazu, dass Hinterfragen halt auch nicht mehr möglich ist. Weil häufig genug ist es ja auch so, dass ich zum Beispiel eine Verständnisfrage stelle und sage, okay, ich würde das gerne besser verstehen. Warum ist denn das so? Weil ich das Gefühl habe, dass es den Beteiligten an der Debatte gar nicht mehr so klar ist, was jetzt eigentlich der tatsächliche Grund ist, warum sie diese ideologisch vorgefestigte Meinung haben und warum, wo diese Überzeugung herkommt, dass sie die auch nie wieder hinterfragen. Und wenn man dann warum Fragen stellt und sagt, okay, warum ist das so?
Ich glaube, dann wird ihnen das schlagartig klar, dass sie das eigentlich selber nicht wissen.
Nee, der Reflex sitzt vorher ein.
Meinst du, die merken das nicht?
Der Reflex, der Abwehr zu sagen, irgendwie nee, du bist doof, ich rede nicht mit dir.
Das ist ja scheiße.
Der setzt halt ein, die Millisekunde, bevor ihn auffällt, dass sie es halt selber nicht mehr so genau wissen.
Naja, das ist natürlich verloren.
Ja. Und das ist, glaube ich, so ein... Also ich will halt einfach das Recht haben zu sagen, okay, ich verstehe das nicht, erklärst mir doch bitte mal, warum ist das so? Und wenn du eine FAQ hast, schick mir die FAQ, den Link.
Ich glaube ja, dass die Leute das als persönlichen Angriff werden, wenn du fragst, warum ist denn das so? Weil du damit ihre Integrität in Frage stellst. Ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwas Irrationales ist, aber so ein bisschen kann ich den Reflex zumindest verstehen, wenn irgendwie... Also ich glaube nicht, dass mir es so gehen würde, aber ich kann...
Guck mal, ich bin halt auf vielen Veranstaltungen. Und da sind halt, also häufig sind halt, also ich mach halt irgendwie so viele Themen so. Viel ist halt irgendwie auch so Überwachungsdiskussion. Und da ist es halt häufiger so, dass ich halt zu Punkten komme, wo Leute dann fragen so, ja, aber ist denn diese Anonymisierung nicht scheiße, weil die ganzen Drogenmärkte und die Sache mit der Kinderpornografie und so weiter. Und ich finde, dass sie ihr Gute und Rechte zu fragen.
Ja, natürlich.
Das ist halt eine Sache, wo ich sage, okay, dann muss ich mich mit auseinandersetzen, muss ich eine Antwort zu finden, muss ich ihnen eine ehrliche Antwort darauf geben, weil ich möchte sie eigentlich von meiner guten Sache überzeugen. Ich bin der Meinung, dass ich eine gute Sache vertrete, also versuche ich sie zu überzeugen und ihnen eine Antwort auf ihre Sorge zu geben.
Genau.
Und jetzt kann ich Pech haben, sie sagen, okay, das überzeugt mich jetzt nicht. Deine Antwort war jetzt nicht das, was mir in mein Weltbild passt.
Oder was aber auch beide Seiten voranbringt, weil du weißt dann nämlich, dass du mir Argumente brauchst.
Oder die sagen, okay, ich verstehe, also das habe ich durchaus auch gelegentlich. Du sagst, okay, dein Argument ist ja zwar ganz interessant, aber in meinem Weltbild, in meinem Wertesystem, ist das Recht oder die Fähigkeit, irgendwie online Drogenmärkte runterzunehmen, wichtiger als deine Recht auf Anonymität. So, wir können es ja sagen. Das ist schon der Meinung, können es ja sein. Und dann kann ich sagen, okay, gut, gucken wir uns kurz die Verfassung an. Die Grundgesetze sagt da irgendwie andere Dinge drüber. So ist es halt irgendwie Abwägung von Wertesystem. Am Ende bin ich wahrscheinlich nicht mit denen einer Meinung. Ich werde sie möglicherweise auch nicht überzeugt haben. Aber muss ja auch nicht. Aber frequent kommt es halt vor, dass die Leute sagen, aha, da habe ich gar nicht über nachgedacht. Also dass sie halt sagen, okay, ja, okay. So ist zwar möglicherweise scheiße, ist zwar eine Abwägung, bei der es jetzt irgendwie kein richtig tolles Ergebnis gibt, aber am Ende ist die Abwägung soweit klar. Das kommt halt eben doch häufiger vor. Und das vermisse ich halt, dass die Leute diese Bereitschaft mitbringen, zu sagen.
Ach, so ist das.
Genau.
Also ich mache ja gelegentlich so Sachen. Ich mag ja den Negativbeweis immer. Wenn ich irgendwie in so eine Diskussion reinkomme, ich gehe in ein Zimmer rein und da wird irgendwie debattiert und zwei, drei Sachen sind einfach so, dann stelle ich immer hypothetisch, ja, was ist denn, wenn es jetzt mal nicht so ist? Oder ich bringe irgendwie ein Argument, was ich glaube, das bisher übersehen wurde. Und das wird häufig als Angriff gewertet. Und dann kommen so Verteidigungsstrategien, die auf mich völlig irrational wirken, wie der führt alles auf dieses Argument zurück. Nö, stimmt gar nicht. Ich möchte aber dieses Argument gerne bearbeitet haben. Oder man muss auch mal Meinungen vertreten, die in der Hoffnung, dass sie sich dann sofort wiederlegen, aus anderen Sachen, die man noch nicht bedacht hat. Wenn ich jetzt sage, zum Beispiel irgendwie auch Nazis haben freie Meinungsäußerungen verdient, heißt das nicht, dass ich das finde, sondern dass ich gerne, ich möchte gerne, dass mir das jemand wiederlegt. Wenn du sagst, wir müssen das jetzt hinsieren und ich sag auch Nazis haben freie Meinungsäußerungen verdient, dann möchte ich gerne, dass du ein Argument hast, was dir wiederlegt.
Meine Erfahrung dabei ist, dass die Leute besser damit umgehen können und die Debatte besser wird, wenn du explizit ansagst, dass du gerade den Advokatus Diabolim machst.
Das finde ich total affig.
Nee, das ist affig, aber das führt dazu, dass die Leute plötzlich in der Lage sind, irgendwie aus ihrem Reference Framework auszubrechen. Und halt irgendwie kannst du als Erfahrung wiederholen. Also dass es tatsächlich so ist, dass in dem Augenblick, wo ihnen klar ist, dass es jetzt nicht deine Meinung ist und sie deswegen nicht at hominem gehen müssen gegen dich, sondern dass du halt tatsächlich nur, um das Argument ordentlich abzuklopfen, gerade mein Advokatus Diabolim macht, dass es ihnen dann leichter fällt, tatsächlich auch zu argumentieren. Also das ist so eine Erfahrung, die ich gerne und häufig anwende, zu sagen, okay, ich mach das mal explizit. So nicht nur, geh nicht davon aus, dass du es merkst, weil du mich kennst, sondern ich sag das explizit, damit du irgendwie nicht in die Verunsicherung kommst, feststellen zu müssen, ob ich jetzt mein oder nicht.
Da bin ich halt irgendwie zu viel mit Computern zusammen und denke, muss völlig unabhängig davon sein, ob ich das jetzt vertrete oder nicht. Entweder das Argument kann auf seinen eigenen Füßen stehen oder nicht. Entweder das fällt von sich aus zusammen, weil ich irgendwas Offensichtliches hier nicht erwähnt habe. Und dann kannst du mir das auch sagen, ohne mich anzugreifen oder du hast nichts, um es zu entwerten, dann sind wir auch weiter als vorher.
Wäre halt schön, wenn das so ist, aber das ist halt in der Regel nicht so.
Na ja, so ist es.
Ja.
Gut, das war es von meinen Punkten hier.
Ja. Na gut.
Ach so, einen hab ich noch. Was mich bei der Facebookfrage so ein bisschen irritiert hat, ist, dass die Leute jetzt anfangen zu reverse-ingenieren, was denn jetzt Facebooks Gründe sind, warum sie dieses und jenes irgendwie tun und nicht tun. Ach so, die meinen es dieses, und das stört mich, weil ich finde, dass das eine Sache ist, die Aktivisten machen und nicht Teil der Debatte. Ja, das machst du, nachdem du dir deine Meinung gebildet hast, dass Facebook Gefährlichste zu löschen hat. Und daraus schließe ich, dass die den Ausgang überhaupt nicht mehr akzeptieren können, dass man sagt, es ist nicht Facebooks Aufgabe, hier Nazi-Scheiße zu filtern, sondern es ist unser gesellschaftliches Problem. Und entweder ist es jetzt, also es ist eine Position, die ich gerne vertrete, weil ich noch darauf warte, dass man das jemand widerlegt. Also ich sage, die Nazi-Scheiße hat da sein zu dürfen, bis es strafrechtlich relevant ist und dann kann die Polizei das wegmachen. Ja, Facebook ist so groß, dass die nicht mehr sagen können, das ist jetzt in unserer Willkür, was wir hier dulden und was nicht. Ich finde auch nicht, dass die Tintenfotos löschen können dürfen. Ja, entweder ist es verboten oder nicht. Und wenn es nicht verboten ist, haben die das zu dulden. Wir würden es ja auch bei Google nicht dulden, dass sie da willkürlich anfangen, irgendwelche Firmen auszublenden, weil die vielleicht irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Gründen irgendwelche, na klar, aber ist ja bei Facebook auch so. Wir merken das halt nur, weil irgendwie die Leute alle nach Pornos suchen. Ich weiß nicht, woher ihr merken wollt, was Facebook da ausblendet und was nicht. Aber die Idee, dass irgendwie Facebook als Firmen so... Ja, das ist ein soziales, eine soziale Instanz sein soll, die jetzt irgendwie gesellschaftlichen Normen entsprechen, die noch gar nicht vernünftig erfasst sind.
Genau, das ist halt genau der Punkt, wo ich es wirklich...
Irgendwelche willkürliche Löschaktionen losdrehen soll, wenn sich genügend viele Leute beschweren. Das ist doch eine Welt, in der du nicht leben willst, dass irgendwelche Firmen einfach willkürlich Sachen löschen können.
Das wird halt im Zweifel gegen dich verwendet werden am Ende. Und das ist halt, als wenn so ein Mechanismus existiert, wird er halt gegen dich verwendet. Und das haben wir ja gesehen.
Ich finde das auch schlimm, wenn es noch nicht gegen mich verwendet wird.
Aber wir haben es ja zum Beispiel gesehen bei dieser Rechte vergessen nochmal, ne? Wo am Ende die Leute, die sich halt da haben, primär rausnehmen lassen aus Google.
Und Leute, die es nicht verdient haben.
Waren halt Leute, die halt echt einen Scheiß gebaut haben und wo es auch besser wäre, wenn die Menschheit weiterhin weiß, dass sie einen Scheiß gebaut haben. Und die Frage dabei ist natürlich die der sogenannten Plattform-Neutralität. Also sollte eine Entität wie Facebook oder Twitter, sollte die eine eigene moralische, ethische, wie auch immer, Meinung haben, in dem Sinne, dass sie bestimmte Dinge nicht doldet. Also klar, bestimmte Dinge dolden sie heute schon nicht. Aber die Frage ist dann natürlich, kann sowas funktionieren für ein globales Unternehmen? Und meine Meinung ist nein. Sondern vermutlich ist es dann eben wiederum so, dass das Internet zu groß dafür ist und es sinnvoller wäre zu sagen, okay, twitter.de richtet sich nach irgendwie dem, der deutschen Rechtslage oder dem deutschen, wie auch immer.
So macht Google das ja.
Und twitter.com nimmt halt irgendwie das amerikanische Referenzsystem so. Vermutlich wäre das der einzige Weg daraus, weil letzten Endes wollen wir nicht, dass Twitter halt irgendwie saudi-arabische oder chinesische Vorstellungen halt darüber, was man posten darf, was man nicht posten darf, irgendwie uns aufdrückt.
So und ich finde das auch total erstaunlich, dass die Leute das nicht bedenken. Ja, dass sie im selben Absatz, im selben Schmähartikel gegen Facebook das als Argument für ihre Zensurposition vorbringen können, dass das ja in Saudi-Arabien auch funktioniert. Tittenbilder gehen ja auch weg. Ja, da müssen wir auch was gegen tun. Das ist kein Argument, warum wir auch das zensieren müssen, sondern das ist auch schon scheiße. Also ich finde das eine absolut furchtbare Vorstellung, dass irgendwelche anderen Leute entscheiden können, was ich sehen kann und was nicht. Weil das greift in meine persönliche Entwicklung ein, wenn mir Sachen vorenthalten werden. Ich möchte gern selber die Abwägung treffen können, ist das jetzt scheiße oder nicht. Na ja, mir zu verbieten, was zu äußern, ist eine Sache. Aber mir zu verbieten, dass ich etwas sehen darf oder zu verhindern, dass ich etwas sehen darf, das geht zu weit, finde ich.
Also es gibt natürlich das Gegenargument dabei, wo man sagt, okay, die Vorstellung der, sagen wir mal, dessen was geht und was nicht geht in der Gesellschaft, den moralischen Grundkonsens, reflektiert sich ja in der Regel bisher in den Kommunikationsmedien dieser Gesellschaft, also in den Zeitungen, in denen was im Fernsehen läuft und so weiter. Und das Internet ist halt der Punkt, wo das eben nicht mehr zwingend so ist. Und wenn man sich jetzt so anguckt, was irgendwie China und Russland und Iran an Internetstrategien treiben, sagen die, okay, wir gehen hin und bauen eigene Systeme, die sich nach den bei uns üblichen Moralvorstellungen und Rechtsnormen richten. Also bei du zum Beispiel oder Vorkontakte in Russland. Ich weiß nicht, wie es im Iran heißt. Also wo man sagt, okay, die Dinge, die du hier nicht sagen darfst, sind andere als woanders. Und dementsprechend finden sich dann halt eben da auch die Leute zusammen. Und natürlich gibt es immer eine Menge Leute, die sagen, das will ich nicht, das ist mir zu eng, das ist mir zu viel Zensur, das ist mir irgendwie zu restriktiv. Und ich gehe lieber halt woanders hin, zu einem Free-for-all-System. Und ich glaube, dass die große Schwierigkeit eben auch wie zum Beispiel bei den geschlossenen Benutzergruppen ist, dass es halt eben keine Deklarationen dazu gibt, wie so ein System gemeint ist. Also dass halt irgendwie diese wishy washy Community-Guidelines irgendwie von Facebook oder von Twitter, die sind halt völlig sinnlos dafür. Da steht halt irgendwie so allgemeines irgendwie.
Die sind auch nicht dafür gedacht, die werden völlig missverstanden. Das ist ein reines Ask-covering-Dokument. Geht es darum, dass Facebook sagen kann, das haben wir aber angesagt, dass das hier nicht geht.
Ja, bloß der Punkt ist, dass eine Plattform, also ich denke, es kann halt eigentlich nur zwei Möglichkeiten geben. Entweder eine Plattform ist neutral, dann darf sie eigentlich wirklich nichts sensieren, außer weil sie wirklich strafbar ist. Oder eine Plattform sagt, ich habe einen moralischen Grundstandard, ich habe irgendwie, in Folge diesen und jenen Regeln, und diese und jenen Regeln haben einen moralischen Anspruch, weil ich möchte, dass hier die Leute, die sich diesem Reference-System unterordnen, sich versammeln. Und dann sage ich das aber auch an. Dann tue ich nicht so als wirklich neutral und habe dann trotzdem halt irgendwie diese oder jene, diesen oder jenen Flavor von reduzierter Meinungsfreiheit hier am Start.
Du, ehrlich gesagt bin ich inzwischen auch überlegen, ob das mit dem, wenn es illegal ist, muss es gelöscht werden, eine gute Idee ist, ja. Da sehe ich, also das war für mich einer der Punkte, wo ich gesagt habe, das kann uns das Internet vom Hals schaffen. Diese Idee, dass in unserem Land dieses und jenes nicht gesagt werden darf, weil ich das für einen Rückschritt halte. Ja, ich finde, du musst alles sagen dürfen, aber du musst dann mit den Konsequenzen leben.
Gut, okay.
Und gerade diese, aber es ist doch per Gesetz verboten, dann zeige ich jemand nur nach China und irgendwie Saudi-Arabien und sage, oder du musst ja gar nicht weggehen, du bist ja bei uns, aber was war denn bei uns alles per Gesetz erlaubt in der Nazi-Zeit? Ja, das reicht nicht, dass es ein Gesetz gegen gibt. Man muss sich generell fragen, ob es nicht besser für die Gesellschaft ist, überhaupt keine Zensur zu haben. Und die Leute, die auf Snuff-Videos stehen, die kriegen dann halt ihre kleine Schmutz-Corner. Und dann gibt es so etwas wie, was weiß ich, 4chan oder... Die Leute werden ja nicht weniger abartig, wenn man ihnen ihre Foren in Deutschland zunagelt, sondern dann holen die sich halt einen VPN. Und genau das ist genau diese Nazi-Geschichte, dass man denkt, wenn ich die ausgrenze, dann gehen die weg. Die tun die nicht, die gehen nicht weg. Die werden nur schlimmer und du merkst das nicht. Also ich bin mir da inzwischen mit zunehmendem Alter, bin ich immer mehr der Meinung, dass diese das und das darf man nicht sagen, ein Irrweg ist. Selbst bei irgendwelchen Nazi-Gedankengutdingern. Ich glaube, wenn wir, daraus spricht für mich die Angst, dass das Leute überzeugt, dass ich sage, wenn wir diese Memorabilia zeigen, oder wenn wir diese Goebbels Propagandarede im Fernsehen laufen lassen, dann gibt es wieder Leute, die deswegen Nazi werden. Und das heißt für mich, dass wir uns nicht zutrauen, sowas inhaltlich zu widerlegen. Und das ist für mich so eine Bankrotterklärung, dass ich das überhaupt nicht akzeptieren kann. Diese Idee, dass wenn wir das zeigen, dann kriegen wir die Leute nie wieder in die Zivilisation gedrängt. Nee, das kann ich nicht akzeptieren. Das hieße, dass die inhaltlich Recht haben, wenn ich das nicht widerlegt kriege. Nee, das glaube ich, das kann ich nicht innehmen.
Gut, also die grundlegenden Eckpfeiler von Nazi-Symbolen und ähnlichen Dingen, die ja sozusagen die harten Verbote sind, Holocaust-Leugnung und so, die sind in Deutschland historisch begründet aus der Angst nach dem Krieg, und zwar ziemlich so in den 10, 15 Jahren nach dem Krieg, dass sich halt wieder eine Nazi-Organisation gründet. Also dass halt die Deutschen noch nicht hinreichend von der Ideologie runter sind und dass halt jede Möglichkeit der Identifikation mit diesen Symbolen, also deswegen gibt es zum Beispiel auch dieses Uniformverbot für politische Organisationen und so, also dass halt diese Symbolik möglicherweise ausreichen könnte, um einen signifikanten Anteil der Bevölkerung zu sagen, hey, wir sind noch nicht fertig, so damit.
Ich kann das völlig nachvollziehen.
Also damals war das halt eine Sache, wo ich sagen muss, okay, das ist halt vollkommen klar. Heute ist es halt auch so, dass man schon sagen muss, dass die Abwesenheit von einer klaren, vereinheitlichen Symbolik die Nazis schon aufhält. Also das ist halt schon eine Sache, die zur Zersplitterung beiträgt. Das sollte man nicht unterschätzen. Deswegen, was das Verbot von Nazi-Symbolen angeht, bin ich eher der Meinung, dass es sinnvoll und richtig ist.
Willst du gegen die gewinnen, weil sie kein Logo hatten? Oder willst du gegen die gewinnen, weil ihre Ideologie sich als falsch herausgestellt hat?
Das Logo-Verbot ist aus meiner Sicht nur eine reine Infrastrukturbeschränkung und das ist okay.
Naja, aber gut, das könnte man als Argument zumindest gelten lassen.
Das wäre ein nachvollziehbarer Argument. Was die Beschränkung von anderen Aussagen, insbesondere Holocaust-Leugnung, angeht, ist es halt so, das ist ineffizient, das führt nicht mehr zum Ziel und das hat halt auch das Problem, dass man sich dieser Argumente nicht mehr argumentativ annehmen kann, weil sie nicht mehr geäußert werden dürfen.
Dann gibt es auch die Gegenargumente nicht mehr im Denkschatz.
Die Gegenargumente vor allem nicht mehr an den Stellen, wo die die äußern. Das finde ich schlecht, das ist nicht gut.
Ich denke mir auch, dass du das erst attraktiver machst. Das wird verboten. Ja, insbesondere in diesem Narrativ, dass du sagst, die Lügenpresse und dann sagst du irgendwie das System, aber es gibt die Wahrheit, sie ist nur verboten. Das ist doch ein perfekter Sturm aus attraktiv machen.
Wobei natürlich man jetzt sagen muss, das ist halt irgendwie Holocaust-Leugnen momentan ja halt so in derselben Ecke wie irgendwie Chemtrails und irgendwie die gefeggte Mondlandung.
Also so ehrlich gesagt bin ich mir da nicht sicher. Das ist einer der Gründe, warum ich dieses Ausgrenzen gefährlich finde, weil ich glaube, dass unsere Datenbasis einfach nicht gut genug ist. Also gefühlt habe ich seit vielen Jahren nicht mehr von Leuten gehört, die den Holocaust leugnen und das ist ja auch gut so. Ja, aber ist es wirklich so, dass wir die losgeworden sind oder sind die einfach nur irgendwie in Sachsen-Anhalt in ihrem Keller und wir kriegen das nicht mit, weil wir die ausgegrenzt haben? Das sind so die Sachen, wo ich mir echt Sorgen machen will. Und ich hätte lieber eine gute Datenbasis, damit ich das Problem verstehen kann, als dass ich irgendwie ein Verbot habe, was dann vielleicht irgendwie...
Ich finde dein Argument in vielen Punkten stichhaltig. Ich finde, es ist halt schon so, dass viele von diesen gesetzlichen Regelungen am Ende auch die einzige strafrechtliche Handlungsbasis gegen die Nazis bilden. Und die aus der Hand zu geben, könnte halt auch ein Fehler sein.
Das ist in der Tat ein Argument, was auch ich für stichhaltig halte. Aber dann mache ich mir Sorgen, muss ich sagen.
Es gibt viel zu Sorgen.
Wenn das das Einzige ist, was sie von ihrem Marsch abhält, dann suche ich mir lieber einen Zweitwohnsitz im Ausland.
Wie gesagt, das geht nicht um Marsch. Ich denke, das Potenzial ist 20-25 Prozent. Wenn du dir die Umfragen zu den Flüchtlingen anguckst...
Weißt du, was wir für eine Wahlbeteiligung haben in diesem Land? Wenn 20-25 Prozent Nazi wählen, ist die Mehrheit. Das ist mehr als die Merkel hat im Moment.
Na ja, nee. Wenn du davon ausgehst, dass es dann das Gefühl eintritt, dass es um die Wurst geht, ist die Wahlbeteiligung wieder höher. Ja, das glaube ich schon.
Also, da würde ich ungern meinen Arsch drauf verwenden. Da hätte ich gerne mehr, noch ein bisschen Sicherheitsabstand.
Ja, gut, der Sicherheitsmargin ist nicht mehr komfortabel, das gebe ich zu. Mehr gut, dann sind wir, glaube ich, durch. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Auf dieser positiven Note enden wir heute mal, nachdem wir euch letztes Mal euch schon fröhlich beschwingt zurückgelassen haben. Falls ihr Lust habt, da gibt es den Flatterbutton, neben der Folge könnt ihr gerne drauf drücken. Wir haben ein paar neue Folgen geplant, wo wir auch ein bisschen rumreisen müssen. Insofern wäre es ganz nett. Ansonsten danken wir fürs Zuhören und dann bis zum nächsten Mal.